And we're live. What's going on brother? How are you? I'm awesome man.
It's good to be here. Good to have you here man. Thank you.
I've never had a guy come in where his own hat and his own tee shirt.
You're number one. You're the first.
I'm surprised by that given how many podcasts you've done,
but that's how I roll.
I don't know if anybody's ever come in wearing their own shirt. Jamie,
any thoughts? Someone has to, someone has to have, I just can't recall it.
Definitely. No one has worn their own hat and their own shirt. Oh yeah.
Maybe Eddie's worn his own shirt, but that's a 10th planet shirt.
That doesn't totally count to share it with my face on it too.
So it's a triple whammy. Ari, Ari,
did you get a new shirt or something? Maybe. I dunno. I don't think so. Maybe.
Anyway, what's going on man? How long are you here for? I'm all good man.
I'm in LA for two weeks. It's my very first time here,
so I just got here two days ago. So just kind of soaking it in.
What's the mind fuck like? It's crazy. Huh? It's weird, man. I feel like a,
I was driving her, I was driving around and in an Uber and it feels like GTA.
I think more like GTA feels like LA cause that's what it's based on. But uh,
it was just kind of trippy and there's levels to the game, right?
The top level of the game is probably either like Singapore,
Beijing,
or Mexico city in terms of Mexico city is the only thing that I've ever seen
that's more chaotic than LA. But LA is, uh, it's, it's right up there.
Yeah. I think Lagos is more chaotic. Lagos, Lagos, Nigeria.
I've never been, that's more chaotic. And Cairo,
I think they're definitely more chaotic. Cairo, Egypt. Really? Yeah.
I find them more chaotic. Well, Cairo man, I would love to go to Cairo,
but I just,
I am nervous about traveling to Egypt and to keep hearing buds.
I keep hearing two stories from people that go all the time. Like Egyptologists,
it's amazing. Amazing. Don't worry about it.
The worst thing you have to deal with is constantly beggars.
And then you hear from other people, fuck that. Don't go there.
It's sketchy. Yeah. I haven't been, I haven't been for a long time. When I went,
it was when I was a kid. Oh yeah. But Lagos,
I've been to more recently and it's certainly more hectic and,
and chaotic and I think here as well here, it's just, it's just interesting.
He's a very, very, very spread out and just seeing, yeah,
just people driving everywhere and not much public transport and all that.
Even compared to other cities in the U S it just seems like a totally different
vibe. But I like it. Yeah.
There's just too many people stuffed into one area and everyone's driving or
they're in an Uber, so someone else's driving them.
So it's just constant driving. Yeah. But I'm happy to be here, man.
It's a little bit surreal, but it's cool. Yeah, I'm sure. Right.
So what are you doing on here? I'm doing, I'm doing this thing. Um, I was, uh,
on the Rubin report yesterday actually. Uh, I've got,
got a whole bunch of contests, guys, that conservative guy,
conservative guy that got a on blaze TV,
the story they wrote about him and he responded, he's like, I'm pro gay,
marriage pro weed legalization, pro prison reform,
pro immigration pro, all these different things.
And yet people are calling them conservative. Well, you know, we live
in a times where everyone's saying is right wing, so let it be so hard to know.
Well, if you're not as progressive as humanly possible,
you're outright well, yeah, exactly. Pretty much.
I've seen all sorts of titles levied onto everybody,
including including yourself. So yeah,
it's interesting for people don't know a Zubie won the world championships and
women's power lifting. Um,
you identified as a woman for a brief period of time, nine seconds left.
It's all you have to do. Yeah. I mean this is the, where we live in dude, that,
that thing blew the internet outlets crazy. Insane how far it went mad. Yeah,
I know. I saw that people, uh, there it is. Let's see,
PSI identify as a woman whilst lifting the weight. Don't be a bigot. You know,
I think, I think when you first talked about that I had like 40,000 followers.
It's now well over 101 hundred and 15 and when I posted it,
I had 15,000 followers, so I've gained a hundred and I've gained 2000 followers.
Yeah, like 105,000 105,000 followers in that video. Congratulations. Yeah,
thanks man.
It really does highlight how preposterous these new world rules that we have in
regarding gender are, but to their credit, the U S power lifting Federation,
I believe that's the name of the organization,
they just banned transgender women from competing. Okay.
Just flat does enough. Enough of that I think if you want to compete,
I don't think there's anything wrong with transgender women competing,
but I think they should compete against transgender women.
Just like how we have men compete against man and we have women compete against
women. Let's have transgender women compete against transgender women.
Let's not deny science and biology just to make people feel better and just to
support some strange progressive ideology. Yeah. I think if they,
if the goal is, that's why I think the goal is more about,
it's more ideologically driven than I think it is actual inclusion driven.
Because if it's just about inclusion, then yeah,
you can either just have an open category like most men's categories already
are. Then I'll actually restrict it to men. It's just, you know,
the best of the best. So anyone can do this.
So either that or if there are enough athletes in whatever the given sport or
competition is, then yeah, you can just have a different,
a different category and that way everyone can be included without stepping on
the feet of half the population. That's a bold move by the men.
Say anybody can be in here, man. That's how it is in pool. You know?
And men can't compete in the women's division of pool,
but women can compete in the men's division. Yeah.
It's the same in the most sports. Most people aren't aware of that.
Most people think that they're,
they have specific restrictions saying only men can do them.
But that's actually quite rare. Well,
there's a lot of successful female to male athletes where females transitioned
to males and dominate male sports. Okay. I didn't, that wasn't true makeup. Oh,
okay. All right. 100% it's never going to happen.
I'm going to try to figure out why. I was like, why didn't I go?
What the fuck is this? What is going on?
I have, well, have you seen this? Uh,
there's a soccer player wants to be in the NFL as a kicker because she,
there's a video of her doing a place kick of a 55 yard or a yard field goal
recently. That's incredible. That's really far, right?
No one coming out or anything. It was just like in practice. But she nailed it,
which is pretty far. Yes. Well, can you tackle kick cores?
They can get hit yet. They're not during the actual play of the kick.
They're not supposed to be touched,
but for sure they're in the play of the field, so. Hmm. Well that's fucked up.
That's not good. That's where the problem is. Carla. Love ya. Yeah,
but stop.
Yeah, that's a bad idea. Oh by the way,
I brought a couple of things for you man. So that's a, is it a Zubie tee shirt?
So the, my latest album that is Zubi tee shirt,
that one actually glows in the dark. It glows in the dark.
It does the CMC that goes on your back. Uh, hopefully it'll kill turtles.
Um, not that aggressively. And that's uh, my new fitness book there as well.
You have a butcher, you already, you already know all that it is. Um,
is it basically, Oh, it's workout routines and yeah,
it's just giving people what they need to know about a nutrition training
mindset, motivation. I just wanted to keep it brief and concise.
All this stuff that I think is most important that people need to know,
whether they're beginners or intermediates. Oh,
this is a good size book to read. Yeah, I put it out first as an ebook,
but then, um, a lot of people asked me to do physical copy, so, Oh, that's cool.
Did those just before leaving the UK and they've essentially sold out already,
so congratulations on that. All you on Fox get out there.
This is a good book for you because it's short. You don't have to like,
people see a fat book, they're like, Whoa, Joe, much work.
But this is a not even a hundred pages. Let's see, six, what is it?
A 93 page, 93. Boom. So there you go. There we go. Strong.
Get all we can all benefit. What is your background athletically, athletically?
Um, I used to actually play rugby. Ah, yeah. So I,
I don't know how much you know about my background. So I was born in the UK.
I grew up in Saudi Arabia. So when I lived, yeah, when I lived in Saudi, um,
I used to play baseball and football or what you guys would call soccer and um,
those were my sort of main sports.
I also did swimming and a bunch of other things.
And then I went to the UK for boarding school actually when I was 11 years old
and there's no, there's no baseball there. So I, yeah,
rugby became my main sport.
I started playing rugby when I was 11 years old and I played that all the way
through to university.
And I got into just lifting weights and stuff when I was in my mid teens.
I have a friend who's British and he says that that is way more common in,
in Europe and the U K sending kids off to boarding school. Um, yeah, I do.
I do think so. Um,
I mean with me it was largely because I was in the American system school system
in Saudi Arabia.
So after fifth grade B because there's a little bit of a transition between the
two systems there, they're quite different.
So it was thought that if I'd stayed all the way up until ninth grade,
then it would be a little bit difficult for me to transition into the British
school system and university system.
So my parents decided when I was 11 same my, my older siblings,
like we all went to boarding school when we were pretty young. So yeah, came,
came back over to the UK and was kind of back and forth between the two
countries for several years and yeah, did things that way. But um, were you,
was your dad in the military or something? No,
my dad is actually a medical doctor. Oh, okay. Yeah. He's a medical doctor. But,
um, he worked for a big oil company out in Saudi,
so we lived there for a couple of, you know, two decades pretty much.
Was that like I enjoyed growing up in Saudi man. Really? Yeah. Yeah.
I actually really liked it. What was it like? It's weird. It reminds me of LA.
I'm being, I'm being serious.
I wasn't ready for that. If there are,
then you don't really don't really see them, um, now, but just a, I think the,
the heat and the, the way that, the way the roads are,
the way it looks actually, like, like, yeah, cause if you live, uh,
like where I lived with sort of an expert community basically.
So we lived kind of in a compound.
So where I lived was a little bit of a little bit of a bubble.
And then outside of that you kinda got what, what I'd call the real,
the real Saudi.
So if you go out into the city or you want to go shopping or something like
that, then you're out there in the real city. So it's very, very different. Um,
it's interesting with me because my,
my family backgrounds originally from Nigeria, but then I was born in England.
I live in England now,
but I lived in Saudi Arabia for 19 years or so.
So I've kind of had exposure a lot, two to three different,
three very different cultures and ways of doing things and even laws and just
the way society is structured and stuff like that.
So I think it's given me a pretty interesting and unique perspective on quite a
lot of things. Yeah. What a broad range of culture that you've been exposed to.
That's pretty fucking cool. Yeah,
Nigeria is a strange spot because I've never, I've never been,
but when you look at the numbers of successful immigrants,
like businessmen and people that have come over from Nigeria and how industrious
they are, and then you look at how many successful Nigerian scammers there are,
it's a wise S very clever place. You got the email from the Prince too, huh?
I didn't get it. I'm sure I have, but I'm,
the one I was thinking about was Jamie,
who was telling me a story yesterday about a guy who, what did he sell?
He sold a nonexistent bank airport. Airport to airport. Yeah, bank too.
That's right. He sold a non-existent airport to obey.
There's been several stories over the last couple of weeks about Nigerian
scammers making big scores.
There's one that I think closed down in Brazilian bank that they took so much of
their money that the bank had to show. The bank had to shut down.
What is it about Nigeria? Why are they so good at that? A lot.
A lot of smart and enterprising people,
and I think if that's channeled in the right way, then that's a very good thing.
I think some people, obviously there's the resources are very limited,
so they're, they're deciding to just go dark and scam people,
but as a person who hasn't been a victim of this, it's quite amusing. Yeah.
If you see, if you
see some of the stuff that that can get pulled off. It's a, it's,
it's quite impressive. Yeah. Pull that story is,
it is very much like men is actually 330 equivalent to American dollars.
Three on 30 million. That happened in the 90s though.
I guess the story is just now going around. Okay. Reason,
but it happened in the 90s which is what this says.
Con man once sold in airport. That didn't exist for 330 million.
Now to stop and think about that 330 million in the 90s it's probably like 600
million today or something. Fucking bananas. Yeah. That's hilarious. Yeah.
There's some, there's some crazy stuff that Nigerian fraudster and con artists.
Emmanuel, how do you spell this? How do you pronounce his last name? N. w. U. D.
E. moody. Maybe moody. No, say it again, I'd guess.
Something like that. What do you, you starting with a M. how'd he sang it?
A moody with an N, but are you manual? How are you doing it?
It's, it's an N, but it's a,
the pronunciation is a little bit different. Say it again. [inaudible]
it sounds to me like just say mood day. No, it's a, it's an N. go ahead again.
I'm gonna call it weirdly enough,
that guy's name is two letters off my actual first name. Really? Yeah. My,
my first scenario. First name is Zhu Bay,
which is spelled N. Z. U. B. E. so that's actually two letters different.
So you just said Zubi would be a little bit more, yeah, as UV is just easier.
It's cool. It's a cool name too. And no one, no one has that. Yeah. Thank you.
I've never heard of before.
So he pulled off the third largest cotton in history by selling it non-existent
airport to Brazilian bank for 250 million us dollars.
But for Nigerian internet scams became synonymous with your original early two
thousands email account and mood day. Did I do it? Yeah. Close enough.
Thank you. Successfully convinced an unassuming bank manager by the name of
Nelson SACA Gucci,
that he was selling a yet to be built airport for a price of $330 million.
As the former director of the union bank of Nigeria himself mu day was privy to
confidential information that was crucial to him pulling off his long con. Oh,
so he knew shit about banking. [inaudible] using the information.
He then impersonated the governor of central bank of Nigeria at the time,
Paul. Okay, here's another one, Paul. Oh GUMA or glaucoma. Oh,
GUMA. [inaudible] so you wouldn't go woo ma.
It's old GUMA or grandma. Oh, go mine. Yeah.
And connected with SoCo Gucci.
We need Steve Aoki to come back and help us with the Japanese name to inform him
of a mouthwatering deal.
Nigeria's plan to build a brand new airport in on another one, a Buddha,
I Boucher. Okay. That's the Capitol. To juice it up a bit. For poorer socket,
Gucci Moo day. Promise, the head of the Brazilian, of the Brazilian bank,
a commission fee to the tune of 10 million us dollars if the deal was approved
to get it over the line.
Soka Gucci paid 191 million in cash as you do.
And the remainder in the form of outstanding interest.
A waited patiently for the construction of said airport. Wow.
Wow. That's the kind of thing you can only pull off one. So yeah,
if you can get that guy again, you're,
I just saw a guy that got scammed and there was a documentary about it.
It was a television show rather.
It was really sad because he was a dude who the older gentleman looked like he
was in his sixties and he was convinced that there was this woman who is a,
you know, his,
his love and she lived in Europe and he traveled there and he was sending her
money and the whole deal and he traveled there twice to meet her.
And both times she couldn't see him both times. Wow.
But he still believed in his daughter was like a,
I don't know what the fuck to do.
This guy really believes and you could see how this loss look in his eye.
Like he really believed that there was a woman over there that was corresponding
with him back and forth and he was sending her money,
like sent her a lot of money. Yeah,
I think it was more than a hundred thousand dollars for I remember correctly.
And he really believed that she was going to be there for him.
And then when you went over there, something came up and she couldn't meet him.
And yeah. See it's weird with stuff like this,
I always feel like in some way you kind of feel sad for the person,
but in another you're kind of like, what? What were you thinking?
Like how do you bounce back from that? Like people hit some lows,
he people hit some lows in life.
How do you bounce back from thinking that there's a girl in Europe that's going
to be your love and sending her $100,000 and traveling over there twice and
getting duped? Both times. And then how do you bounce back from that?
And the first thing you should do is not tell anybody like daughter take,
take the El without just quiet. Just take it.
Take it quietly and privately in Dona don't tell people his daughter knew about
it. Okay. So it was like, and then the camera crew,
I mean this motherfucker brought a camera man. I don't know why.
I think the show is very vaguely remember this and I think it was about 10 years
ago. I think this show was all about people that were getting scammed. Okay.
It was about why people get scammed and what, you know,
what is it that makes people believe ridiculous things. Yeah.
But when it comes to romance and money,
those are the two where people get greedy. Yeah.
I was literally gonna say it's greed.
It's greed cause only greedy people can fall for some of those things. I mean,
you see some of those scams and it'll come through saying, okay,
I've just inherited $30 million and a,
I need somebody in the U S with a U S bank account to help me out with this,
and I'll give you a 10% cut. And you know,
that should raise a lot of red flags for anybody who's kind of thinking with
that with the head on straight. That's true.
But if you pay attention to televangelists, do you have those in the UK?
Not like the ones in the U S in the U S it's another level you asked.
It's another level, man.
Everything's another level over here. Yeah, everything's bigger, including,
I mean, you get those mega churches and I don't,
there's probably one or two mega churches out there in the UK or in Europe in
general, but not one or two years. That's it. I don't know.
I'm not even aware of any,
I'm kind of hedging my bets saying that's probably a couple,
but I'm not aware of any, not that churches do you think we have in America?
How many do you think we just haven't Texas. Yeah,
Texas might have a million of them. Yeah.
Cause I mean the guys who run those things, they're like,
I mean they did themselves as themselves or celebrities, right? Yeah.
There's at least 10 cause it says, here's an article about the 10 largest.
So in Texas? Yeah, just in Texas. Wow. Yeah.
The, those things. Olsteen guy, he's a fucking baller and a half.
He's got private jets and mansions and he, he bought a, a stadium.
He bought a sports stadium and converted it into his gigantic mega.
Apparently mega church is defined as a church with over 2000 members over 2000
that's a lot.
And there's a given 10% at least 200 to Texas and everyone's given 10% or at
least most of them are given 10% right? Yeah. The tie thing correctly,
what is the, how many do you think there are nationwide? Let's take a guess.
How many mega mega churches are there in America?
So do we know how many there are in Texas? That's just 10 biggest executives.
At least 200 and Texas. That's 200 and Oh wow.
Ah, 200
and texts, 200 200 fucking people ripping people off.
200 if there's 200 in Texas. Wow.
I'm going to say 3000 nationwide. I was, what?
I'm going to say you're going to say three thousand three thousand mega churches
nationwide. Yeah, I, I'd approximate around that. I'd approximate around that.
What do you think, Jamie? You got your hand on Google though. Don't be cheating.
Oh, too late.
I'm already got answers cause I'd imagine some States don't have any,
what did you think it was going to be, Jamie?
I a couple hundred 500 but there's a lot of that, a lot of them that even,
I don't know, I didn't think there was that many.
That's somewhere in the range of, well,
so since it's 2000 that seems low because like I went to Catholic church and
there's more than 2000 people at some of those churches. Right,
but they're saying mega churches, right? Yeah. But that said,
if that's how they 2000 members are in the church, well,
I mean maybe they just think 2000 scammers that says there's 1300 such
Protestant churches, but then it goes into like,
there's 3000 individual Catholic parishes that have more than 2000 people. So,
Hmm. It gets squirrel. That's what I'm saying. I think several thousands,
like the big building complex, there are large churches that are legitimate.
Yeah.
Like they're really following the Christian doctrine and they're really holding
real services and they're really wanting good for VBL.
And then there's those dudes that have the super expensive tailored suits and
they drive around in rolls Royce prosperity gospel,
they call it prosperity gospel. If you, if you give then you will get,
see what I have. You will get what I have is
you bring me your money. Yeah. It's um,
I've got the [inaudible]
flying. Oh wow. Oh wait, wait, wait. [inaudible] you haven't seen this.
[inaudible] wait, wait. What is missing? Mississippi pastor dub,
the flying pastor glides into Christmas service.
He's gliding in with an angel outfit on. Please rewind.
I want to see that along. Oh my God, this is so crazy.
He's got an outfit on. He's flying from the sky.
Oh my God. That's his move. That's a good move. Okay.
Because now everybody knows about this move. Oh, he's bringing checks in.
So I was gonna say, is that Beyonce spinning around, you know,
pink had one of them goddamn things. No, she didn't. Um, she was doing Ariel a,
those silk things fell in. Oh wow. Fucked herself up.
Really bad. Like she had like internal bleeding and no,
no fluid in her lungs. Yeah. It was bad.
Wow. Yeah. No. These, these mega churches thinking like, I think, you know,
a church, like you said, with a congregation of over 2000 people,
if they're sticking to the script and doing what they're meant to be doing and
not trying to, yeah. At least their fleece, their congregation,
then absolutely nothing wrong with that. It's um,
the ones who use their position of power and their cult of personality to then
just enrich themselves at the expense of their congregation.
Those are the people I think God's going to be having a serious word with.
God's going to be very mad at them. I don't think it's going to be pleased.
Interesting that they like the Nigerian scammers,
they're just playing off of weak minds.
They've just tapped into this group of humans that's gullible and believes
nonsense and they, they know how to, they know how to pull those strings. Yeah.
I think it's, uh, like I say,
when I say I think God is going to be having a word with those people,
I mean that, I mean that very seriously because I think it's, you know,
it's one thing ripping people off or doing some kind of scam or deception or
something.
It's another one using the power of religion to do so where you know that this
is what these people believe in your,
in this position of power and you're now just using that authority to, you know,
buy yourself and you, you Bentleys. And I mean it wasn't there one where I'm,
what's that guy's name? Is it Creflo dollar? The while he think he had,
um, I think he had a G four yet he owned he, yeah, he wants, yeah. And he,
he,
he did basically like a crowd funding appeal to his congregation saying that his
PRI,
his current private jet is the old model and he needs the new model and he crowd
funded, I think to get the G I, I saw this thing, I was just like,
Oh my gosh, like you're shameless and you're famous.
Like I bet Taylor Swift could crowd fund a private jet as ridiculous as it
sounds. Probably if you just were shameless. Yeah. If you just like,
I don't give a fuck. I need a private jet. I want y'all to buy it for me.
Here's the link.
I think that's shameless.
But to say you're going to do this and you're going to go to heaven because you
did this, that's Creflo dollar say that you're going to go to heaven,
if you will. His whole thing is the prosperity gospel. That,
so I'm sure there was something in that, you know, be generous now and you know,
you'll be rewarded later, Claire.
It is Creflo dollar would get $70 million Gulf string G six 50 yeah,
that's not right, man. Whoa.
So somehow or another he crowdfunded $70 million. The is that real?
Did he really get that much money? That is a lot of money for a jet.
Why do they cost so much their minute a metal? What are they made out of?
What's going on in there that's so much money. How has that $70 million?
Like if that was a car, right? The same shape, you'd be like,
wow, it's nice car in the air and it flies. It does fly. I mean,
when it goes in the fucking air, I understand, but how much different is it?
It's a lot. I dunno. It's safely goes in the air. Right? Right, right.
But how much different is it fast? Build it very fast, right?
It's definitely different. But how much different,
because if a car was that big, if a car was that big, it was a dope.
His car ever like a Bentley may have bus, let's just say it was $1 million.
Like right. I think in the new Bugatti's, like $12 million, something like that.
Yeah, but that's a different kind of animal, right? Because first of all,
that shouldn't be $12 billion. They're fucking people, right.
In their household,
but also they broke world records like the new Bugatti hit 304 miles an hour,
which is insane. That is insane how fast that is.
I personally don't like them. I don't like the way they look.
I think they look kind of gross.
If you bought, there's a difference.
I was just thinking if you bought a booth that Bugatti, you get to drive it.
You buy this plane, you don't get to fly it.
That's true. Unless you take the lessons. Why would you want,
if you're going to, yeah.
I think if you're going to spend $70 million on a plane,
I don't think you should be one. The one flying in.
I think you should have some,
some staff asking price $67,950,000 that's a stage where they just rounded up to
70 what does it say? Total hours. 1,616 and you don't want to use it.
Total landings. Oh, so this is light hours.
They're all used. Yeah.
They don't make lots of new ones that gets passed around and yeah,
it was made December 16 2014 yeah,
it's a five-year-old jet and it's still 67, nine.
I just wanna make sure the interiors clean,
total landings chicks 125 go with that fucking thing with a bus.
When those little blue lights, what is it? A black light? Yeah. Oh my God.
Just splatters TJ's all of this year. If you got Dan,
Bill's Ariens jet. Aw man.
[inaudible] as Coke in between the seeds and just calm everywhere. Oh,
Dan's beard hairs. Everywhere you go, you're picking up beard hairs.
Definitely make sure a pastor gets that one. Yeah, I mean what, what are the,
what's the building cost of making a jet?
Like it's amazing that they retain their value.
To give a yacht is way more like super yachts, you know,
like hundreds of millions of dollars for and great. Yeah. Yeah.
I know some a guys, the Fertittas that own the UFC,
they have some preposterous yacht. I saw Steve jobs yacht,
um, after he was dead in Italy. It was a, it was in the,
on the road in Italy and the guy was with a pointed out to me and it looks like
an Apple store. It looks like a floating Apple store once it Venus, is that,
Oh yeah, there's a couple [inaudible] yeah, that's it. Okay.
Play that God damn floating Apple store doesn't look real. Floating Apple style.
It looks weird and the back is weird saga. Everything is run with IMAX. Yeah.
That's how it looks. And if you look like in the back windows,
it's like everything seemed really,
seems like an Apple store and everything is run with IMAX.
Those IMAX screens are all over the place. [inaudible] trusting.
Yeah. Google needs to step it up. Develop an Android boat, Android phone.
It's a cool looking boat, but yeah.
How much did that fucking thing cost that had it cost $500 million or something
ridiculous. Yeah. Right. You've got to step up the game.
Zubie yeah, man. 100 million.
A hundred pounds cost more than a hundred million. Yeah. Oh, euros. Yeah.
What is the euros to pounds? It's almost
almost, it's almost the same. Oh really? Almost parody now. Yeah.
Is pounds almost double what all changes, right? Yeah.
You're your own pounds or almost one-to-one now. Oh, okay. Yeah.
It's like 1.03 or something.
Used to be awesome to go to Canada because if you go to Canada,
your money would go way further. Cause then United States doctors,
the last time I came to the States it was two to one pound.
Like for every a hundred dollars with 50 pounds.
Last time I came and now it's like 50 pounds is like $60 now.
So fucked up. Yeah. That Brexit
founds taken a beating over the last couple of years. Is it? Um,
is it weird the whole Brexit thing over there? Um,
for people who are really into it, I don't follow it that hard.
I'm kind of just bored of it. I'm just kind of just do something,
just make your decision and while the decision should've already been made three
years ago, but just execute it like, let's go, let's get out of here. Um,
what's the general consensus of like your friends and people that you hang out
with over the people? I hang out with, um,
those who live in London are primarily on the remain side.
Those who live outside of London, primarily on the, on the leaf side. Oh.
So it's an urban thing like a United States very much like the cities are
anti-Trump and the farm areas. Yeah.
So if you imagine like London and the Southeast are more equivalent to kind of
like the,
the coastal cities and Pacific Northwest of the U S in terms of being much,
far more liberal in general, um,
and being more pro EU and pro remain. Whereas if you go outside of that,
if you go up North or to the Midlands or anything like that, then people are,
um, yeah, I guess both more conservative, I guess in a way.
And also a lot more NTEU in general sentiment [inaudible] so a lot of the people
in London and around London work totally blindsided by the Brexit vote in the
same way that a lot of people, I imagine,
live in Los Angeles and New York were blindsided by the Trump presidency. Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
Have you ever seen the girl with the sock hat on the glosses on knees? Yeah,
I've seen her. Yeah, I watched that one on when I'm feeling a little down,
I watched the Trump reaction video that seems to sort of embody the beginning of
of the chaos that has ensued because things were kind of squirrely before Trump
was elected, but now they're just off the reservation. Yeah,
well that's part of how he got elected. I mean, I was one,
I remember in 2015 before he even won the Republican nomination and I was
talking to people, both friends and family and saying,
I think he has a good chance of winning and people were looking at me like I was
like, I was smoking something. I'm annoyed.
I didn't put any money on it because at the time was there gambling online
gambling? I think the first time at the time I first said it,
I think it was,
I want to say like 40 to one or 50 to one or something ridiculous like that.
I called it on my Netflix special, get the fuck out crazy. I'm like,
we are that close to president Trump. Well, you travel the country,
right.
So I think your perspective is going to be a lot more balanced and actually
accurate. Also, people who don't realize the problems with Hillary,
like she's that I don't think,
I think that if they had gone with Bernie Sanders,
Bernie Sanders could have really won. I really think you could have won.
He could have beaten Trump. Yeah. I don't think Hillary is ever going to win.
She's got too many skeletons. There's too many things you can point to.
There's too much. Too much madness. Too much smoke. Yeah.
This is way too much way. Just way too much. Yeah,
it's been going on like most of my life too. That's the thing.
It's like this isn't a new person.
She's been involved in this thing for decades.
And then when the actual DNC was rigging the primaries against Bernie and Donna
Brazil wrote about it in her book and you go like dirty organization,
it's dirty. Yeah. And she is.
That's the thing that people always forget with Trump is people are always, Oh,
how did he win? Or why did you wonder what,
and it's like you always have to consider like there's all the factors in his
favor, but there's also, I mean, who he was running against.
That's a big part of it. Yeah. That's a big part of it. So people are acting,
acting as if the alternative was so much better or something. And I'm like,
they fucked up, but it wasn't so they fucked up. Bernie could've won. I really,
I really think you could have won.
It would have certainly been more interesting because I know a lot of the Bernie
people went over to Trump rent. Yeah. And say, you know, as time goes on,
one of the things that I've been noticing, and uh,
I watched the David Pakman video the other day where David PAC
was pointing out Trump slurring his speech and I had no idea it was that bad.
Oh, really? I haven't seen it. I hadn't seen it.
There was one time where he literally, I mean,
literally like he's fighting through like say if someone puts you on pain
medication, they said, Hey Zubi you gotta make a phone call? Yeah. Oh,
this is really important. You gotta talk to a bank and be like, yo, that is me.
Have you ever gone bless America? Like,
have you ever seen the video of him sweating? No. No dude.
And it's not edited or anything. Oh, no, no, no, no. It's,
he has a really hard time saying God bless America. Pacman pointed out,
it looks like he's like wrestling with his tongue. Something wrong on.
Fair enough. I mean, when I see him, I mean,
that guy's got some crazy energy for, how old is he? 70 73 70 30 that guy's got,
some guys got energy, man. It's called pills. Medicare
fires. You know,
you could fucking hop your grandma up on fucking speed to cheat up all kinds of
shit to say, look, it's legal.
You need get a doctor doc. I'm suffering. I've a, I've got fatigue. I've,
I, I have a chronic fatigue. And the doctor go, well, good thing for you.
We've got a thing called Adderall and mix. That's what it is.
It's something man. Yeah. It's something, I mean,
we've talked about it on the podcast too much. I don't repeat myself. Yeah.
But I really do believe that he's on some kind of stimulant.
He's been on something in the past and there was allegedly a, um,
pharmacy in New York that was prescribing him diet pills for years.
And some journalists uncovered the whole thing. I'm not surprised. Yeah. Look,
I know a lot of people on it, man. Some of them that are functional,
some of them that are off the fucking charts crazy because of it.
Because this video, yeah, this is the video,
but just play the one where you see him slurring his words. Yeah.
Back up a little bit. Raw there. Play that. Listen to this,
our hearts and minds to possible and possibilities.
And finally I asked the leaders of the region political and religious,
Israeli and Palestinian,
Jewish and Christian and Muslim to join us in the noble quest for lasting peace.
Thank you. God bless you. God bless Israel.
God bless the Palestinians and God bless the United States. Judge.
Thank you very much. Oh, those are the last couple of words. Yeah, bro. Yeah.
That is listen to you. Yeah. Now listen to him. Yeah. Listen to you.
Now listen to him. That's a guy who's hopped up on something.
Either hopped up on something or he's dying. It could have been drinking.
He's having, naw, he doesn't drink. He doesn't drink.
Doesn't he know that's cool. Drinking gets in the way of pills, bro.
You don't wanna slow down the pills. You here for progress.
We're here to complete tasks and set goals and conquer and make America great
again.
Mega the way he was a campaigning with the amount of energy that that dude had.
I mean, you gotta assume for a seven year old
man, they, they got a medicated on some shit. Yeah, it's entirely possible.
Surprise me. Caden people. Yeah. We were talking about, um, we'll fuck,
was it that told us about Hitler? Hitler with the a were,
I remember who brought it up first, but it's been like three weeks ago now.
Yeah. Hitler, when he went to meet Mussolini,
he was apparently super exhausted.
So they pumped him up with steroids and liquid cocaine, cocaine.
They injected him with steroids and cocaine and then he liked it so much.
He asked for a second dose and they thought they thought it was gonna kill him
and he said, give it to me. And then he went to visit mousseline.
He apparently chewed mousseline his ear off for five hours.
Mostly Laney was apparently thinking about getting out of the war and Hitler
talked him out of it. Just fucking spit and Coke talk at them.
The worst thing you can give to that guy,
that's a fucking Ric flair right there, man. Yeah, I mean,
I think they've done that to people forever.
Apparently that was the case with Kennedy. Kennedy.
They would shoot him up with them. Pheta means really? Yeah.
See if you can find that. Just to keep his energy levels. Okay.
Kennedy was very sick apparently before he died and he had severe back pains.
IQ is, he was really banged up and he had some sort of a disease.
I don't remember what the disease was, but during much of his presidency,
they would put him on amphetamines to keep him active.
They didn't think about the consequences of those things back then.
I don't think they truly understood addiction back then.
I don't think they truly understood the way it affects your decision making
process. Well, that's back when they used to just, you know,
advertise heroin in the newspaper and stuff as a sort of general paint that in
the 60s when was that? When was that? That was what decade was that?
They used to just,
you'd look and you'd look in the papers and they just have like such and such
heroin that take this there and when they used to give women a tapeworm eggs is
diet pills and all that crazy. Yeah, those were the original diet pills, right?
They used to give a women a tape tape,
tape worm eggs so that you ingest it and then obviously the tape worm grows
inside of you and eats all the food and you lose weight.
We have so much to talk about, let's find out, but Kenny first,
so we've heard of dr feelgood. That's who his doctor was.
Dr max Jacobson was injecting him and his wife and a list of other people.
I thought it was a Motley crew song. Wow. Okay. Dr. Jacobs. Oh my God.
Here we go. What does it say here? A the most, scroll up a little bit.
The most famous doctor patients were president and Mrs. Kennedy.
Dr. Jacobson frequently visited the white house and often traveled with the
Kennedys in 1961 for example,
he went with the president to Vienna for a summit meeting with Khrushchev and
Dr. Jacobson said an interview gave the president injections there in addition
to the Kennedys,
other persons who are patients of the doctor included Truman Capote,
Cecil beat to mill, Eddie Fisher, Allen Jay Lerner. I don't know who that is.
Representative Claude pepper of Florida, blah, blah, blah.
A bunch of other politicians probably in Tennessee.
Williams. Wow.
Including included among the number of a number of other prominent patients of
Dr. Jacobson have been a bunch of other famous people, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And extensive inquiry also turned up the names of well over 100 others in
ranking positions in government, journalism, finance industry, society,
and several entertainment fields who were said to be patients of Dr. Jacobson,
but who could not be confirmed as such. What does it say about, okay.
It cannot be said with certainty that the Kennedy's or with a few exceptions,
any other specific patient received amphetamine. It is known,
however,
that Dr. Jacobson uses unusually large amounts of amphetamine in his practice.
The doctor's office reported the Dr. Jacobson buys amphetamine at the rate of 80
grams a month.
That is enough to make 100 fairly strong doses of 25 milligrams every day.
So he's got a hundred people taking hard core doses of amphetamines every day.
25 milligrams. Apparently. They're saying it's a big dose. I dunno.
What is it a lot? If you just take an Adderall, she was like 10 to 20 max.
Sometimes people that are crazy to get 45 you're fucking grind an enamel that's
injected too,
right to the source. Fuck stomach acids get in the blood, baby.
Whoa. Yeah. I think it's been going on forever. Yeah, it seems like it. Well,
I mean it's about energy, right? Like look at poor fucking Joe Biden.
That poor bastard. You've been paying attention to him a little bit. Yeah.
He's bleeding from the eyes. Oh yeah. I saw that on TV.
His eyes just start bleeding. Yeah. How old is he? 1 million.
He's a million years old. He's only like 78 or some shit.
He's not that much older than 78 is too old to be. It is too old.
If you're that guy,
I mean you could be 70 like Jacqueline Lane when he was 78 look fucking
fantastic when he was 90 was pulling boats. Yeah. Did you ever see that?
I don't you to think upside. Zappos is eyeball. Yeah. No that's too old man.
You don't and for evasive answers, evasive answers.
Like I can't see no fucking bleeding and of his eyeballs.
That's like some hell raiser type shit. Cause if you do get into office,
I mean you age at like four times the normal rate or something. Anyway,
he thinks he's been in office but that's horse shit. He was a vice president.
I suggested the vice president is pipe.
Probably the easiest job in the history of the world.
The Brice vice president is like slightly easier than hosting fear factor
[inaudible] that's what I think. You just kind of show up.
Everybody else does the hard work of fucking guide. That's a bear.
That's barely a job. That's like the best way to go into hiding,
become vice president. Nobody gives a shit about you. Okay.
Unless something happens to the president, you've got to step up. Yeah.
But nothing ever happens. Yeah, it's true. The only time it's ever happened,
the last time it was going to, Kennedy got shot.
That was the last time and most likely Lyndon Johnson was in on it. Oh,
Hey. How about that? Oh, I cannot confirm nor deny.
I have no opinion knows who knows what was in on it. But um,
that guy ain't gonna win the, the, ah, the idea that they're,
they haven't pulled that guy aside and go, Hey Joe. Hmm. No,
he's the front runner though, right as it, I don't think anymore.
I think Bernie and Camilla Harris are very close, so Trump is,
should win mainly, but because Tulsi gavage shutdown Camilla Harris in the Bay,
they pushed her out of the debates. Even though on multiple polls,
she has enough support to be in the debates.
They're excluding her from the debates because she attacked Camila Harris and
rightly so and accurately. I think she's on the wrong,
I think she's on the wrong side. I think she's in the wrong party.
Thinks she should be a Republican. I do, yeah. Wow. Yeah.
Why she has all these democratic ideas though. Yeah, that's true.
But given the way the democratic party is going now,
I think she's far too sensible for them. I don't think so. I don't know.
I think they'll come around. Maybe if she doesn't win this term,
she will be president some death. Okay. I really do. Yeah. I watched,
I watched your, um, watched and listened to your, your podcast with her.
So that was interesting. I'm saying few, I saw that one.
I saw the Andrew Yang one as well,
and I think it would be awesome if we had a legitimate badass woman president.
I think she's the one. She didn't do it.
I think it'll ha it'll certainly happen eventually. No question. I don't know.
Next, next time. I don't know. Yeah, I don't like to make public predictions.
I do think if things keep going the way they will,
I do think Trump will take it fairly easily. If they say Latin has changed,
they let Joe Biden get to the front. Trump's gonna win. Yeah. Trump lead him.
Yeah. He'll chew him up,
calls him sleepy Joe Trump will be grinding his teeth and fuck it.
Spit now fillings.
I mean fucking amen in Trump is a funny guy. He says,
funny shit is funny. He knows how to shut people down.
Did you see the thing that he did though with the hurricane map? I didn't know.
He was telling people that the hurricane was headed to Alabama. They're like,
mr president, there is no indication that hurricane is headed to Alabama.
So he posts a map with the hurricane path with a Sharpie that draws Alabama also
in the path of the map, bro. It's so pull.
The one I loved was the, Oh, look at this.
Like you see the path that hurricane and then there's a Sharpie drawn around it.
Okay. See, you see, this is the original and then you see the left,
that Sharpie drawing somebody true.
That was the exact wording that you use today. I saw on the news,
they were saying that like white house officials wouldn't deny that he didn't do
it or something like that.
They wouldn't deny that he did or didn't do it.
So no one's saying the president did not. Definitely did not draw that.
He probably was like, Kimmy, the map. Oh man. We'll just put it here. Just draw.
I bet. Where's Alabama? That one. Okay. Edit in. Just add it in. Yeah.
That guy's funny, man. The, the thing with the Trump tower
on Greenland, that was amazing. Yeah. That actually, it's funny,
that tweet, that was very funny, but it's, you know, he's, uh,
and then you guys have your own Trump.
That fucking dude named Boris Boris Johnson, the new prime minister.
He looks like Trump. It's crazy. He's got the crazy hair. Yeah, yeah. Know.
I mean, and he's the one that, he's a pro Brexit guy, right? Yeah.
He was one of the key leaders of the Brexit campaign. So it's happening.
Well, backlash, man. Backlash. I mean, I understand it completely.
I understand it completely. I mean, yeah, a lot of it,
like there are a lot of different factors, but that's a pretty key one.
And just, you know, the,
the condescension from people in certain cities about the rest of the country or
all the other cities. I mean,
you see that it's the same thing in the U S and in the U K like I was saying,
I mean,
when you've got people even just referring to all of middle America is what they
call fly country. Yeah. Like, dude, you can't call it, you can't say that.
And then expect those people to vote. People even, not even just that,
it's expanded even further. And the best evidence is Dave Chappelle,
Dave Chappelle's, recent sticks and stones, Netflix documentary.
For whatever reason,
rotten tomatoes thought it would be a good idea to only have it reviewed by five
super progressive critics. Only critics.
They closed it off to the public. Yeah. It had got 0% on rotten tomatoes.
They then opened it to the public and it got 99% of course,
if that doesn't show a crazy disparity between, first of all,
the idea that you're gonna suppress it,
like you're going to say 0% so no one's going to watch it and we're going to
shut Dave Chappelle down. He's canceled. Fuck him, but people love him.
You can't cancel someone who doesn't care, man. Well,
you can't cancel Dave Chappelle. You can't. But on top of that,
like the,
how would they not understand that someone is going to know that you're not
opening it up to the public and that once it does get open to the public,
you're going to get a massive whiplash,
a backlash where people gonna to come and even if they didn't want to vote on
it,
now they do and now they're going to give it 100% or 99% I knew I had to watch
it when I saw how all the media channel,
many of the media channels that I really dislike and do not respect.
We're coming so hard at it and saying, Oh no,
you don't need to watch it and all this. I was like, Oh,
this means I absolutely have to watch it.
The guardian game in the UK gave it one star and then I saw a vice saying like,
don't watch it. A VOC saying don't want, I was like, okay, this is,
this means that I have to watch this. This is going to be good. Well,
I wasn't disappointed.
Influence of a small group of relatively small group of human beings that are in
charge of these media conglomerates is,
it's really astounding and that they,
it's not just opinion, right?
It's like they're trying to get people to behave
and think the way they do. It's activist. Yes, it is activism. Yeah, and it's,
it's also, it's undisguised activism.
It's very transparent activism. It's in a postage journalism.
I really wish there was a place where we could go where we can get 100% unbiased
information and news and we can get an honest perspective of both sides.
This side believes this and this is why they believe that,
but this side believes that.
And this is why they believe that it's very hard to do.
And if you have a podcast,
one of the things that's really interesting is if you even talk to someone who
has an opposing point of view of yours or who is right wing or who maybe has
some questionable ideas,
you are somehow platforming them and supporting their idea and then supporting
some all why. All right. Ideology and it,
there's no room anymore for people to have conversations with people with
differing opinions and just find out why there is. There is.
It's right here. You've, you've literally created it, man. Seriously, you,
you've,
you and a handful of other people have created this and it'd be a nice fact.
Go somewhere. If I could go somewhere things. I mean,
it's nice that I'm doing it, but you gotta trust me.
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing.
I'm not the guy to be distributing information.
I'm certainly not the guy to be analyzing things. I'm too busy. Okay?
I have too many other jobs. I got three kids, I got three jobs,
I've got a lot of hobbies. You know, I'm fucking busy, right?
I'm not the guy to go to that's going to give you an in depth comprehensive
analysis about the way the world works. It's not going to happen.
I'm not your guy. Yeah.
But what I am as someone who's interested in talking to people,
what they should have is someone who has my,
I don't want to say my sensibilities, but my, uh,
my willingness to communicate with almost anybody.
And then also someone who does a real exhaustive research,
does real exhaustive research on the actual facts behind all these critical
issues that are gonna affect everybody. I don't see that anywhere. Well,
you're not gonna,
you're certainly not gonna find it on television just because the format just
doesn't allow for that. You've got the time pressure, the advertising, all that.
It just simply doesn't allow for it. And then in, you know,
the way newspapers and journalism is going, I mean,
the stuff that's been paying is the click baity sort of stuff. You know,
the stuff that gets people outraged, stuff that gets people fired up.
Highly partisan stuff. It's, you know,
being sensible is not the, in the old media,
that's not what seems to be profitable. I know. But is that everything?
Is profitability anything? I mean, where's real journalism? Yeah, because I,
I feel for real journalists because I do think that they are fighting for their
lives in terms of this world. Like nobody, I subscribed a few different
things.
I subscribed to the Washington post and the New York times and a few other
periodicals on mine where I pay money to read their stuff online because I think
they have valuable contributions. I just,
I don't think many people are doing that. There's so much free shit.
Vox is free. All these other places are free.
And so if you're only going with free shit, you're only going to get bias stuff.
And you're also only going to get stories that are commercially viable to,
to the people that are making it. And why would they be commercially viable?
Well, they gotta be clickbaiting.
That's the only way you get people to pay attention to shit. And that's,
I think that's, that's already starting to stop working.
You think something click baity stuff. Yeah. I don't know if you,
I mean if you were to think back a couple of years ago where, I don't know,
you'd go on Facebook and you'd get all these kind of like Buzzfeed things and
you had all these new media companies that sprung up and sorta took advantage of
the clickbait era. But people are pretty,
people have become quite wise to that.
Now I think and people are starting to realize,
I mean I think if you went back even a decade,
I don't think most people thought that the media in general was particularly
biased. Um, maybe they would've thought, okay, maybe that one and that one,
but not just generally. Now I think if you were to survey people,
like a lot of people understand that even the ones that are supposed to be
impartial, things like CNN, things like through New York times,
especially when it comes to the opinion pieces, you know,
people know that those things are not just giving it to you straight and they
know you're, you're getting some spin,
some cases you're getting it from a totally partisan angle.
And I think if people are up front with that, if they're like, look,
we're a conservative news outlet. Look, we're a liberal,
left-wing news outlet and that's the filter everything is coming through.
If they're front up front about that, then you know, I'm kinda like, okay, yeah,
that's, that's fine.
But if people claim to be unbiased or claim to be totally impartial and just
bring you the facts without putting too much opinion or spin on it and then you
can kind of see through that and see that's what they're doing and they may not
even know that they're doing it right.
Cause so many people get stuck in these echo chambers.
So I don't think all of it is necessarily on purpose. Um,
but that's just how it is. And I think the vibe I'm certainly getting,
I know with myself and with other people and listening to what people are saying
is people are starting to notice it a lot more.
I know you've talked a lot about the online tech censorship and bias and stuff
like that, which is another thing that again,
I think if you went back 10 years ago,
I don't think people thought that Facebook or Twitter or YouTube or any of these
things were biased. Whereas now in 2019 it's like, okay,
you've got enough examples to see, okay there are diff de platforming,
a lot of people have certain political persuasions and then you've got other
people who are outright calling for violence or just saying like crazy stuff or
threatening people and they're fine.
They're turning a blind eye to it and it's so,
it's just in your face and it's kinda like,
well this isn't me being a conspiracy theorist. It's just, look,
they've taken that person, that person,
that person, that person, but all these people, they're still there.
So these rules are not being applied fairly. That's certainly the case.
And it's also certainly the case that they're trying to manage this stuff at
scale. Right? So they're trying to manage,
like one of the things that I got from communicating with Jack Dorsey,
the head of Twitter, is that you saw him when he got hacked. Yes.
When the head of Twitter gets hacked, you're like, damn. [inaudible].
Apparently they used a very simple way to do it, SMS text,
because they used to have a system we could send texts through, you know,
to Twitter through text messages and they hacked it that way. Yeah.
That was so weird. I was on Twitter when it happened. I was like,
scrolling through my feed. I was like, what? Wait,
what's going on here? And it was just, it is fun, right?
Isn't it fun when someone like Jack gets hacked?
When someone like jackets hack, it's like, wait a minute, wait a minute,
wait a minute. The guy who's the fucking head of Twitter,
who's been at the head of this,
the helm of the controversy when it comes to censorship,
it got hacked and his pin tweet is something about a,
how Twitter wants to open up conversations and get somebody very, very positive.
And then underneath it it was just like, Whoa.
I think he really does want to open up conversations and he really does believe
that block chain is eventually going to have virtually every conversation that
everyone has ever had ever available for everyone online.
And that the idea of censorship is going to be preposterous in the future.
And I think he's right.
And I think that's one of the reasons why his own personal philosophy is that
Twitter should essentially be a town hall.
And this is what he and I is when we got into it,
particularly with the Tim Poole and Vigia when we talked about it,
his philosophy,
his personal philosophy is that Twitter should be available to anyone to
communicate their ideas and that it should operate much like the first
amendment. So you know,
the only thing you can't do is call for violence and dogs,
people and things along that. Are they going to bring people back then?
They should have told him he should. She said they should.
And then he said that there was a thing, an idea of a wild West Twitter.
Like you'd have two Twitters, you'd have a curated Twitter,
and then you'd have a,
anything goes to it or a gap to bring back Alex Jones and whoever the fuck else
has been banned. Who's, who's a few people, the big ones. Laura Loomer. Yeah,
all them. Megan Murphy. Yeah. Megan Murphy is a ridiculous way.
She's been on my podcast.
I want to get her on know we've talked about having her on a,
I hope eventually I can, if people don't know what happened,
she got banned from cheese, what's called a turf,
which is a trans exclusionary radical feminist and trans exclusionary,
that's a weird word. Exclusionary. I don't even say it right.
I say exclusionary, exclusionary.
Radical feminist is someone who thinks that trans women are not women.
And so she has said, you know,
publicly that she doesn't think that trans women should be in feminist spaces.
Yeah. Communicating as women.
And so she got into it on Twitter with someone and she said,
but a man has never a woman and they lifetime ban. Yeah. They know.
They actually told to take that down. So she took it down,
but she made a screenshot of it and then she posted up the screenshot that said
a man is never a woman and they gave her a lifetime ban,
which is goddamned hilarious. Yeah, I mean that's crazy.
I don't get the lifetime. Oh we were talking about gay people on Milo as well.
Of course. Smile know got taken off several years ago. Let's see.
They wouldn't tell me exactly why Milo got taken off.
They said that Milo had harassed Leslie Jones, but he hadn't.
He made fun of her.
But apparently there was some allegations that there was many accounts other
than Milo's connected to Milo that Milo was operating.
This was the allegation.
I don't know if that's true and this is one of the reasons why they had made the
decision, but that might not be the case.
That might be the case of someone saying, Hey,
we suspect that these other accounts are also run by Milo.
So cause they wouldn't say it on the podcast. Yeah. Thing is, look,
even if even if someone did get banned for genuinely violating some terms of
service, the idea of a lifetime ban, I mean forever,
you're 90, they're still ban. That's insane. I mean, you can be a,
you've got,
you'll have literally convicted hardcore criminals on there who can have Twitter
accounts and stuff, but it's like, okay,
you said something that someone didn't like. I'm having them again.
This is another Gavin McInnes. Yeah, there's, there's quite a few.
There are quite a few.
Now the problem is when you ban these people the way there,
they've done it radicalizes people in opposition. Absolutely.
And it also looked, here's the reality, man.
Twitter is a terrible way to communicate. It's fucking terrible.
Limited amount of text. Text is a terrible way to communicate. Sure. I mean,
we were just talking, Jamie and I were talking yesterday about, uh,
disagreements that people have had that we know through emails like that.
Emails, like someone reads it wrong and then someone sends you a message, Hey,
you know, this guy's disrespecting me. And then you go and read it and you go,
what is going on here? Man, cause people read into texts, they,
they, they just decide that things in text means certain things.
They might not really be accurate. Yeah. I think that's a problem.
And I think that the,
the method of communication through Twitter is just a terrible method.
Twitter is good for letting people know you got things coming up. I'm like, Hey,
I've got an album out. Yup. Bang, perseverance, perseverance.
Zuby Twitter's good for, uh, I love it for posting science stories. Okay. Yeah.
And interesting stories. So is amazing.
Twitter is the best social media platform by a mile.
I don't interact with people anymore. I don't even read it. I don't blame me.
I send things
to the world that I think are interesting and I hope people enjoy it.
Like genuinely, I don't want, I don't bash anybody on Twitter.
I don't attack anybody on Twitter.
I've had opportunities where someone's informed me of something that someone
else has said and I'm like that. It's not even sure people say, well,
it's stuff about you man. Oh that's interesting. People say some,
some wild stuff about just, just generally. But you know,
I think when it comes to communication,
the further you move away from face to face, real world communication,
the further you abstract away from it, the worse the communication method is.
And the easier it is to, I mean cause you lose so much. Yes. Um,
and then the easier it is to intentionally distort it is it is. And you know,
you lose. So a phone call, I mean real life is the best.
And then second to that,
probably a video chat after that phone call after that,
a text after that, a tweet and the further you abstract away from it,
you just lose more and more of the actual communication.
Cause you can't read any body language now. There's no intonation in the words.
You can't tell. I could say something now and it's like, you know,
you say something with a smile on your face. It's Joe, he's joking.
But if you tweet those exact same words, one person over read it and be like,
okay, I think he's Joe. I think he tweeted that with a smile on his face.
Someone else's like, no, that's, that's dead serious. Like that's a,
that's something crazy he's saying there and nobody really knows.
And then because it's all public, I mean it's,
Twitter is weird because there's not,
it's like just going into a room and just full of people in just shouting
something. Yes. It's not like a forum where it's like, okay,
this is the topic we're talking about this right now. Twitter is just like, ah,
this is what I think about anything.
And you just throw it out there and then you wait for people to people to come
back with stuff. You know what's interesting is on someone tries to be,
someone tries to establish a narrative about themselves on Twitter.
Like,
Hey listen as a happily married man who's a Christian or this and that and that
like, wait, Whoa, Whoa, Whoa. Who are you talking to? Well you,
you shout in the South. What are you trying to,
are you trying to describe yourself for people so people have a certain way of
viewing you? Oh yeah. Cause that shit ain't gonna work. Yeah,
they're immediately going to go, why are you talking like this?
What kind of person says these things?
What kind of person like tries to establish a narrative about them? Well,
they do before they even talk. I mean, people do that with their Twitter bio.
Oh yeah. They'll do it with their bio. I mean, some people will put in,
you know, this is my species, my, my location, my pronouns,
my religious or nonreligious views. You know who I vote for?
Like all of that. Yeah. Here's my device folks.
If you see anybody that says they them as their pronouns, black them,
just black them right now. No. Got some,
I've got something I'm trying to coin is Zumiez razor,
which is that if someone on Twitter has their pronouns in their bio,
then there's like a 95% chance that you can just dismiss them. Yeah.
Dismiss a lot of what they are saying.
Suebies razor is a very easy way of describing it.
I'm going to use that for that online. I'm going to call it zoomies raiser.
You know what's interesting? I noticed that you have an phone. What Apple did.
The fuck people is a, when someone is about to write a tax to get those dots.
Dot, dot, dot, dot, dot, dot, dot, dot, dot.
To let you know their typing and then it goes away like, Oh,
they were gonna type something and then they fucking stopped.
Whereas at the Android, you send a text, you get a text back.
Maybe you do, maybe you don't, but you don't know if anybody's in the middle.
They could write some long,
lengthy bullshit texts and then wake up sober and go, Oh my God.
Thank God I didn't send that. You know, it's like emails.
You don't know whether or not someone's gonna. Someone's replying to an email,
but that dot, dot, dot, dot, dot, dot. You get that on Instagram too.
If you send a DM to someone that says typing. Ooh, that's a weird one.
Gives people anxiety too. It does. You can annoy people. You can,
you can just start typing and then just walk away. It's just a typing it.
Go to the movies. Just,
just keep the app open and use other apps. Yeah, it's crazy.
All the social media stuff.
I feel like we're just right now in the middle of sort of the biggest experiment
amongst humankind that's ever taken place and we're, you know,
we're all Guinea pigs in it.
Like we have no idea what the longterm implications and repercussions of some of
this stuff is going to be.
But it's like we're all just in here using all these different platforms and uh,
I mean you can already see some of the effects. Yeah. It's, uh,
it seems pretty well documented that things like depression and anxiety are
going up as use of social media goes up. I mean,
literally during the introduction of it with the smart phones,
it's the combination of smart phones and social media. Yeah,
I think that does it. I don't think, it's not smart phones alone.
It's not social media alone.
Like when you had to go login on a PC to use my space or Friendster or high five
or whatever,
and then you go out the house and you're no longer on it is just a fact.
People are constantly carrying it around and trying to get this validation.
And you know,
you've got Instagram now talking about potentially removing likes or [inaudible]
YouTube,
removing views because they're seeing how it's affecting people and all this
kind of stuff. And yeah, it's not going to work though.
[inaudible] it's too late and the box is open. You know,
you're a grown ass man. So for you you can handle all this shit. Yeah.
I think the real problem is kids. Yeah.
Kids growing up being 13 and 14 having Twitter and Instagram and Facebook and
having anonymous people say really shitty things to them.
Anonymous friends or enemies at school. That's a real issue.
In Jonathan Haidt wrote a great book called the coddling of the American mind.
Great book. It's a really good,
great book and it goes into that and dev and it really made me fucking super
nervous for my kids like growing up and developing during this time where we
have this, you know, sort of uncharted territory of social media.
There's not like a lot of documented history of use.
So we can go back to a hundred years of people using social media and this is
the way to do it healthily and this is the way to, you know, there's,
there's people that are just fucking tweeting all day long.
It's just an experiment I think going crazy, pulling her fucking hair out,
taking pills, barely,
barely getting by in this life and just tweeting all day long. Yeah, it's weird.
And you've got people have different and then you've got people who just post 10
selfies a day, the same, same picture, same face, and just do it.
Really? Yeah, there's some, it's generally women,
but there are some people's profiles you can go and it's just,
you go on their Instagram page and it's just all just their face. Same face,
same pose and just the times a day just there. But over and over again,
you see that video clip where the girl had the selfie stick and she's,
she's trying to get a photo of her own, but with this, with the selfie stick,
she's like on a deck chair. I've seen that. Yeah. That's hilarious.
And someone took a picture of her doing it so her ass is straight up in the air
and she's got the selfie stick up like that. Oh my God.
She's trying to get that perfect ass angle. I was like, wow,
that's a 2019 [inaudible] Thursday. People are so thirsty.
They want likes so badly. Yeah, it is. It is very weird.
And then you've had people who have died because of it. Oh yeah. Yeah.
I don't even Canyon. You keep falling off the grand Canyon. Really? Yeah.
Falling to their death. People falling off buildings.
There was a couple where the is, she doesn't even have a selfie stick.
I was not sure. Still loving our generation. Who posted that?
Oh no, she, yeah, she has got herself his Dick Barstool.
She has got the selfie style. She does have a self mistake. Oh,
she put it on the selfie stick. Look at that dirty bitch.
[inaudible] C C C right there.
She's got her arm up and this is like not good enough.
Let's get that selfie stick out. Oh my God. God. That is so hilarious. Strange.
But imagine if that's your daughter. You're like, mm.
[inaudible].
It's really strange cause if I done, cause I think it's,
it's both exposed people for what they are,
but it's also changed people's behavior. Yes. You know,
people do things now that you just wouldn't even,
something as simple as taking a picture of your food. Well,
here's something that never existed before.
So this is a, a move that women do where to put my phone. Oh.
Oh my God. I lost my phone. Oh no, that's probably in my car. Oh, well no. Yeah,
here it is. Hold on. My purse. My man.
This is something that you see now that you never saw before. Ready?
Here's the look. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Chicken neck. Girls do that to try and get the right angle.
Got to get the right side. Nobody's do that before. No. Right.
That's a new thing. That's a new one. You'd have their head. Yeah.
It's taking photos of yourself is a pretty new concept. I remember in my space,
people used to do it in the mirror,
in the bathrooms and bathroom and stuff like that,
and that's when they first got thirsty. Yeah.
They first started seeing six backs and nice asses and people, yeah,
it's just weird.
I just wonder what the effect will be in a couple of decades to be honest with
you. Coincidentally,
my space is also right around the time that white people started figuring out
that they like big asses. Something's happened with that. It hasn't there.
I was talking about this with one of my friends, like go to like the Dukes
of hazard. Yeah. Okay. This is what I was talking about the other day.
A Catherine Duke.
She was like one of the hottest women on the planet earth and like 1980 and
she's a beautiful lady with an ass as flat as this table.
[inaudible] she probably never did a squat. Yeah. Ever. And uh,
nowadays that won't fly you. You, yeah. You can't get by.
You can't get by without a big caboose. It's weird. It's um, part evolution,
part diet part. I don't know. Doctors, doctor, a lot of squats,
squats, you know,
going to the gym has become a lot more mainstream though in general, hasn't it?
It certainly has, but there's a lot of gals out there faking stock. Yeah.
There's a lot of gals out there with some plastic shoving their buttocks area
and ready for this Don Don Don ass cancer.
There's a a whole group of humans that are experiencing cancer in their ass
because of ass implants.
Really the same kind of cancer that many women get when they get breast
implants. Oh, it's not 100% of them, but it's,
it's, it's relevant. Like there's an issue.
There was an article written about it recently that women are starting,
their doctors are starting to find the same types of cancer that some women get.
Cause you know,
everyone's body reacts differently to everything and there are certain risks
that you take if you get some sort of an implant in your body that your body
rejects it or that it causes cancer.
So women are getting cancer of their ass. Man,
that's a rough cancer bro.
You got to go in there and scoop out chunks of your butt and maybe you die.
Maybe you die. It's not worth it because you weren't willing to do squats.
Just do squats. That's the thing you can do squats.
It's like if a guy has a little Dick, all right,
and there was a machine that let you build your Dick up.
There would be a line around the block for that machine. All right.
I mean everybody would be on that goddamn Dick machine,
but women have a way to build their ass up and it is a real thing.
You can do squats and dead lifts. You can run stairs,
you can do squats and dead lifts and you will get a big firm ass man. It works.
You know you're not going to get a J-Lo ass unless you've got those hips. Yeah.
Have you seen when guys do the, um, like the six pack implants?
So of course you must've seen like since you know synthol and stuff where they,
where they, yeah. Inject the oil into them. It's like the muscles will swell up.
Yeah. People do weird, crazy. People do some strange, some really strange stuff.
The six back one is the weirdest though, because it's just this,
it's just there all the time. Yeah. Even if they raped. Yeah.
But it looks weird cause some, even if they,
even if they gained weight and the rest of their body is kind of flabby,
you still just got it looks like a Ninja turtle. That's what, yeah,
it's like bullshit. That's the perfect scribe. God. Yeah.
It looks like bellyache AB implants over his keg.
It looks like a bows Bowzer from Mario. You know,
show me in the large
version. Jesus Christ. That's weird. Right? That's so crazy.
Because that guy's fat. It just doesn't look right. Wow. That's so weird.
And that's definitely fake isn't only that guy just does a shit ton of setups.
No, cause he's got a barrel chest, but he doesn't have any, any pecs,
which is weird. Who is that said celebs thing.
This guy was on big brother in the UK and he definitely got an AB plan. Yeah,
that's, that's a fact. Yeah, 100% I'm pretty sure. I don't know.
I'm pretty sure that are, yeah, that's it. It shows up plastic surgery,
pasta cabs. Go back to that image that you were just at before.
Go back to where you just wear it. No, scroll down. No, no, no.
On the other side, scroll down though. The,
the boxer right there and the left hand side. Yeah.
That guy was a boxer above it right there. That guy had pec implants. Okay.
That was a boxer with pec implants and like crazy plastic surgery face.
He uh, we, we,
we watched a video of him before he was fighting in Mexico.
We had like fixed fights in Mexico.
Remember that this guy had like fake everything,
like fake fake chest and fake muscles and just so weird. Cause it doesn't even,
cause it's so strange though, cause it doesn't even, it doesn't even function.
Yeah. Right. If you had big arms or arms, arms that look big,
pumped up with synthol or whatever, but then they're not even strong. Right.
And then the problem is look at that neck, grab ahold of that neck, bro.
You ain't,
you ain't defending any chokes or that does a tiny ass neck.
Oh that, that, that,
that one there that before and after a really shows on the left, the abs.
Oh yeah, go to that far left. Yeah. You can. That really shows that. Wow.
That's incredible. My God.
But what's weird is because your abs only look like that if you're leaning like
if you're F if you're flexing them, yes, but when they do that,
it's like that all the time. All the time. So it just,
it just doesn't look right. Look at that. That's incredible. This is different.
This is not an implant,
but like sculpting in some way with that guy did also lose weight between those
two pictures. Yeah, he certainly did.
He certainly dropped his body and it looks like he's arms and chest got bigger
too. He leaned out. I'm not buying that one.
And then that you got that synthol guy up there. I don't know. People do.
Some people do some strange things.
The thing is a woman can get things done like boobs and no one cares.
Guys, look, she looks hot. But if a guy's got like a fucking sock and it's,
Oh Whoa, that guy.
We're looking at a girl who has fake implants of her, her abdomen,
her abdominal muscles that are so obviously fake that they're over her ribs.
Yeah.
Like those muscles are literally over the rib cage where they don't even belong.
No. Hmm. That's nuts. Is it face to steroids?
So you can see like, look. Yeah. So look at that guy.
You can see when he's sitting [inaudible] go to that guy. The abs are still,
it's just so ridiculous. It just doesn't look right. He is too, bro.
You got to lose weight if you're gonna rock fit.
That's so lazy in eight pack too. That's so lazy. See, abs are a weird one.
Cause if you really desperately wanted to abs, everybody can get them.
If you just work hard enough, you know abs, it's not like,
what is that? Jesus Christ. Guys,
abs and then a weird swelling underneath. Yeah. Him,
his flesh Fanny pack. Yeah, but that's what is that right? Don't, I don't know.
Sorry. What is that? That's just a weird picture. Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
But guys with fake things that like get no respect.
You know what I mean? A guy with a fake Dick, like, get out of here.
A guy with a fake PEX kick go away. What is this? Whoa.
Injected into his balls. Oh my God,
man dies after injecting silicone into his testicles for sex cult game.
Okay. Yeah, that's all I had issues.
But like dudes with fake pecs and guys would fake muscles.
Like nobody wants to see that shit. No, I just go to the gym and eat. Right.
It does work. Yeah. We imagined really if there was a Dick growing machine,
you know like a squat rack for your Dick boy,
boy would there be aligned. But after I wouldn't,
it just become like that would just become the new norm. If everyone,
the girls will be all stretched out. Everybody have a giant hog. But you know,
I don't, I don't actually think most people would just lie.
Most people don't go to the gym. I mean,
you've already got this option to increase your muscles and make yourself look
better and most people don't do it.
So I'm not convinced that if it took actual work and effort,
I don't actually think the majority of people would do it.
I think you're a hundred percent correct. Yeah. If it was difficult,
it was hard work. That's why people want these operations.
All they have to do is go to the doctor's office.
The doctor's going to take care of everything. Mike,
I'm going to put you under and when you wake up,
you're going to have a hog of a lifetime.
You're going to have the giant PEX and a false sculpted six pack and synthol
stuffed muscles.
There's one video of this guy that's Brazilian dude who's got these synthol
muscles and he's dancing and it looks like he's got water balloons all over
[inaudible] talking about like the, the,
the body dysmorphia where people just don't see what other people see.
Like same as anorexics and same as, you know,
I guess bodybuilders have that same issue,
like a lot of really enormous bodybuilders still feel like they look small.
Yeah. It's, it's weird man. It's, it's weird.
Like I just think if you want to change your body,
you want to change your physique, you want to feel better,
you want to feel more confident. There is a way to do that. Yes.
That doesn't involve paying tens of thousands of dollars or taking massive
health risks or getting caught up or anything like that.
Just go to the gym train. It works. Yes, it really,
it really does work. Not everyone's going to be able to reach some elite level,
but you know, everyone can look better, man. Everyone can look better.
The the people that have sympathy for people with physical deformities,
you know, issues that you just can't
grow muscle or something's wrong with your body or you have a disease like that.
I get it. Then for those people,
I do truly hope that science comes up with a solution and it's through some sort
of CRISPR type engineering. They're able to, here's, here's a question for you,
Joe.
Do you think that there's any sort of limit in terms of what science maybe could
do but sort of should not? Do you know what I mean?
Like as science advances and things get a little more crazy and they're looking
into things like making people immortal or all that kind of in your own mind,
do you think there's like a level where it's like maybe we should like leave
this alone and not go, not go that far? I don't know what you think.
Even if you do think that, and I,
I'm sure that you could find examples where I would say that's a bad idea.
It's not going to matter because I think that people are going to do it and if
the United States isn't going to do it, China's going to do it. Yeah. I mean,
I think China's already experimenting on people pretty cool,
pretty radical ways and they're doing, yeah,
they're doing CRISPR on fetuses and you know, they're,
they're going to do genetic engineering. I think it's in, you know,
just in the cards in our lifetime we're going to see some product of genetic
engineering that some super freak athlete. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I mean,
when you and I are old men,
we're going to be watching television or whatever the fuck they have back then
or in the future rather,
and we're going to see someone who can fucking jump over buildings.
We're going to see someone who can, you know, literally fly over cars,
just leap over things and just someone with preposterous physical attributes.
That's all created in a laboratory. I mean,
if you think about the greatest athletes the world has ever known, you know,
you look at like the,
the very best physical specimens that humanity has to offer and they just
figured out, okay, well what are the traits and how do we,
how do we impart those on people and how do we actually improve them?
How do we double them in triple them? You know,
you know what mile Staten inhibitors are a yes, I do.
They allow the muscle to grow far beyond what they can and they exist in,
um, for whatever reason, um,
in some cows naturally and also whippets. Yeah, bleach. It's,
it's really weird, so weird. I've shown people pictures and they're like,
that's not real. It is real.
Something with whippets apparently when they breed them, you know,
like breeding dogs is weird.
Like I have a friend who has a chocolate lab and their eyes are about as close
together as my two fingers are. That dog is fucked. Like it just, it just like,
I don't like being around it. It'll bite you. Like, it's a, it's,
it's overbred like it's like some fucking West Virginia hillbilly just left
alone and some small town,
they can't get anywhere and know there are people like that. Right. Yeah.
Inbred people. Well there's inbred used to be a big problem and with royalty,
right? Yes, yes. Yeah. Cause they only had to breed with other world to yeah.
Um,
this whatever reason when you breed whippets and something goes wrong cause
they're just breeding them with other whippets they develop this fucking
preposterous ability to grow muscle and they look like hope dogs. Yeah.
That's not, that's going to happen to people. Man.
There was already a boy who was born in Germany I believe,
who had a natural uh, problem.
He's like his body naturally had the same issue that a whip had had.
Have you ever been something, I think I know,
I'm trying to actually remember his name cause I know the kid you're talking
about if he can pull that up. Well,
there was one kid that would call them the young hall turned out that his father
was actually injecting with steroids when I was a little kid, which is awful.
But this is a boy from Germany who had this myostatin inhibitor problem and he
was fucking Jack. How old? He was a little, yeah,
like four or five at the time when I saw the pictures and I'm,
I'm talking just thick muscle caps, you know,
he looked like polo coasts. The guy who fights in the UFC fucking jacked.
That's nuts. Jack. Jack Little baby. That's so bad. We're going to,
we're going to see the Hulk and all like a real live version of the Hulk.
It's going to happen. I don't know that, that kind of stuff.
It does freak me out because it's kinda like eugenics 2.0 right. Yeah, I didn't,
you know, I'm just kinda like, man, well how,
where's this stuff all gonna all gonna go. Well,
there's a beauty in our diversity, like our physical diversity.
This is a beauty in the factors,
really tall people and really short people and really smart people.
Really stupid people. And sometimes stupid people really good at certain things.
Sometimes smart people are really bad at other things and there's a,
there's like a,
there's a beauty in the chaos of human life is that we are all weird and
different and, and if you can find your way,
everyone can make some sort of a contribution.
It's not that everyone's going to make some sort of a contribution,
but it's possible that most of us can find something where other people find
value in what you do and you could do something in an extraordinary way. Yeah,
definitely.
I think I'm a great way to stay humble is to always remember that like everybody
is superior superior to you in some way, shape or form, right.
You know you,
it seems like you've got people who are kind of awesome at everything or
whatever, but it's like, you know what,
like every person out there has got something that,
especially if they tapped into it and they actually reached some fraction of
their potential,
then people have people who are capable of all kinds of crazy things when they
actually do it and they train and they work on it.
Another perspective enhancers that the grave beckons. I mean,
we're all going to die.
They're dwelling on what you're great at or not great at in this life.
It's like, okay, you ain't got much time, bro. Seems like you do,
but it'll be there before you know it.
The grim Reaper is going to be knocking on your door. Yeah.
I think that's motivational though. There was a little bit about that kid. Yeah.
Yeah. She was four years old. Fucking wow.
Jeez.
Is that the kid he does? Gymnasts think the best I could.
I thought this is who you're talking to. You type in myostatin inhibitors. Yeah,
but the, I don't know if it's coming up on him.
I don't know if they have studies on him, but I don't know if that's him.
He's Jack though. He's fucked. He's so jacked.
He's four years old and he's built like a 17 year old super dude.
Look at the who got the shit? Yeah, the shoulder striations. Yeah.
That is so unusual. No, that's not normal. No. So unusual.
That guy's gonna fuck his way through grammar school. That's not normal.
Big tank. Yeah.
We're going to see a lot of those.
We're going to see a lot of those coming out of China or my words, you know,
he's not that big anymore. It's not the beginning of the older now.
That's him now. Oh, okay. What happened? They stop lifting weights.
They got him off the ship. 15 now maybe see when I see something like that.
And then I also see him lifting weights. He's younger.
I don't think this is the same one. And cause that was also, he's Italian,
right? A Romanian. Romanian, yeah. Um,
there's another kid from Michigan, which he said Germany.
So I thought it was a German kid. Yeah, I know what you're talking about.
But we could search for a long time before we find it and interrupt.
The podcast will never get done. But uh, I think we're going to see that.
I think to answer your question though, yeah,
I think there's probably a lot of things that we shouldn't do, you know,
but what are those things and whose to decide and does it really matter? I mean,
look,
it's entirely possible that this fucking plan is going to get hit within our
lifetime by a giant asteroid and we're gonna wipe us all out possible.
That's possible. It's possible. That's not outside the realm. No,
I mean this isn't there a big one. It's supposed to,
there's a real chance it might hit around 2029 fuck,
I thought we were all supposed to be marked by in 2000 or so, but I dunno,
that was just the Y to cash.
That was just the bug was gonna stop civilization in its tracks.
I can Alaris is that when they were coding,
they didn't take into account that the 19 hundreds going to switch over to the
two thousands I remember even even at that time when I was a lot younger and I
was thinking surely they worked that out.
Like surely it'll just go from 99 to zero. They're not,
it's not going to just explode. And they call us all this guy.
They worked it out and you had people like hiding underground and doomsday
prepping and all that.
Oh imagine if you spent all your money building a bunker in your backyard and
then the day after 2000 poke your head out and birds are chirping people
driving. Hi Mike. Hey Cindy. Fucking normal.
You definitely a shit bunker. Go to stay in there to stay safe face.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean look, people are fucking silly,
but we all, we all have this understanding, this appreciation,
the fact that we, you know, civilization like our grid,
our power grid is fragile, the internet is fragile. There's no fucking,
there's wires that go under the ocean that connect
us to other countries. That's how it works. Yup.
The internet is literally wires laid down at the bottom of the ocean that
connect us with Europe.
Yeah, it's nuts. It's crazy how quickly it's, how quickly it's happened as well.
I know, it's interesting with me,
I mean I was born 86 and I remember in,
you know, the late eighties when you couldn't even render a circle on a screen,
right? Like they didn't have the technology to make an actual circle.
So in all the video games and graphics and stuff,
it would either be a square or at best a hexagon or an octagon because you
couldn't actually do round curves. And that's in my own lifetime.
And then I remember, I remember the early days of the internet when I was,
especially when I was in boarding school and stuff and using geo cities and
Netscape and all that kind of stuff.
And it's just kinda crazy how it's gone from that and all these Atari 2,600 and
these very basic video games and stuff like that.
And the Apple two ease with the big floppy disks and all that stuff.
And I'm just like, man, I'm only, I mean I just turned 33 and I'm like, man,
that's just in my own lifetime.
So in another 10 20, 30 years, it's,
yeah,
it's amazing to just think of what stuff's going to be like cause they'll look
back on what we have now and what we have.
Everything we have now is going to look like the Atari 2,600 those to me right
now, there'll be looking at these phones and being like, Oh my gosh,
people used to use this. It's inevitable. Yeah.
You know what's interesting is that there's,
there's nothing classic from our lifetime either classic classic like uh,
like there's
classic things from like the night,
like classic muscle cars for example from the 1960s people love them.
Classic cars from the nineties can go fuck themselves. No,
nobody wants a 1990 car. Get the fuck outta here.
With that already classic by like the 80s though,
like classic rock was already classic run. It happened quick. Yeah.
Well people realize that something had happened.
There was this like this blip in time where people went wild and they,
you know, we talked about it with Aoki yesterday.
We were talking about Hendrix and Janis Joplin and Jim Morrison.
These people just were a part of this revolutionary change in culture.
And then it was swiped out in the 1970s so by the time 1980s came around,
when I was in high school,
1970 cars were fucking classic cars.
They were classic Malaga,
1970 Chevelle in 1981 when I was 14 was the shit.
It was like a classic muscle car. Like my mom had a 1970 Barracuda,
1971 Barracuda when I was 14 in 1981 that was the shit.
But it was a classic car was an old car, but it was 10 years old. Okay.
It's like we realized some way that the culture had shifted and that was never
gonna happen again because cars were dog shit in the 80s I mean,
they were just dogs. If you didn't have a Porsche,
Porsche is probably the only cars that are still cool.
Like I have a 1993 RS America.
It's a very lightweight air cooled Porsche, super lightweight,
stripped down, no air conditioning, no radio. It's a fun car.
And so I was like one of the rare cars,
it's worth a fuck from 1990s one of the rare ones. Yeah.
Most of the shit from that era is just nonsense. You know,
for whatever reason they just, the eighties and nineties like people just said,
they went into this dulled zone of creativity. A lot of complaints,
a lot of things. Classic video games though, I guess music,
music and video games. Entertainment. Yeah. Music films, comedy, comedy. No,
that was Eddie Murphy. Delirious was from the 80s yeah.
A lot of Richard Pryor shit was from the 80s it was amazing.
Maybe not in terms of um, tech or manufacturing,
but in entertainment I think entertainment and culture,
I think some key stuff happened in that decade. Well,
there's these bursts of novelty in the creativity and we're certainly in the
middle of one right now.
Like right now is probably one of the more interesting times to be alive in
terms of like constant innovation. And new things being created.
Apple has apparently some new AR glasses.
They're about to release augmented reality glasses. Yeah.
I also just think now the time we live is people just have the opportunity and
potential and power people have as individuals now is insane. Yeah.
It's, it's not what it's ever been before. I mean,
nobody told you to start this podcast, right. This is just something you,
you started and you've been doing it.
You've been doing it now for a decade plus,
and you've got the ability to broadcast this out to millions of people.
Doesn't matter where they are in the world. I mean, I live in the UK.
I flew over here to come do this podcast and I've had people in the UK. Oh,
cool. Awesome. You're going on Joe Rogan. Yeah. I watched that and it's like,
that's thousands of miles away and you've got people all over and you can reach
all of them largely for free too. Right. You can just do that.
You can put something out on your phone,
you can reach millions of people through their,
whatever it is you're trying to communicate,
whatever it is you're trying to promote. I mean, that's you.
That's what I really enjoy. The fact that it's free. Yeah.
I think that's the coolest aspect of one of the,
the big media things today, which are podcasts,
is that you can just get them. It's just like, I download so many of them, man,
I get 'em all the time and they're there. They're always new ones.
They're always available and you get them.
I love the fact that you can get them instantly to, yeah,
you have a podcast on it, a real talk with Zubi real talk with Zuby. He'll talk.
So I can go right now to my iTunes and I'll type in right here and here we are.
We guard.
There we are in the podcast app and we're going to go with real talk with Zubi
talk with Z. You there it is. Bam.
Real talk with Zubi. Here it is. Boom. Cause,
and I'm a subscribe and then I'm gonna see, Ooh, check Mark.
And that's a downlow Casa. Awesome. Everybody else go do the same right now.
Everybody goes through the same of this.
I mean this is what's crazy is it's not like instantaneously play it.
I mean we're having this conversation by benign. I mean you can.
There we go. That's crazy.
My shout up that that's the most amazing thing in our lifetime.
It is. Yeah. You just pulled that out of the air. This thing is like in the air,
it's not connected to shit and it's just pulling things out of the sky with a,
you know, it's not, I feel like people are aware of it, but they're kind of not.
Most people are not. Do you know what I mean?
Like people that are our PE people, people use it.
Everybody knows the internet exists. Everyone knows social media is there.
I don't think people realize like what you can really do with those tools.
It's like, yeah,
you can sit there on Twitter and be mean to people in Detroit and troll and
troll and go on YouTube and write mean comments or whatever. You can do that,
but you can also just create something from nothing. Right?
If you're a comedian, you're a musician, you're an actor or whatever,
you can just go and make a YouTube channel, create new channel,
create new account. Yeah. And you can just start putting stuff out there.
You've got a phone which can record in HD four K video. Good audio.
I mean it's nuts.
Even if I just go back to the 90s or early thousands and you look at music
videos and stuff like that,
and an iPhone or a standard Android can record better quality video than the top
tier stuff that they were recording music videos and films with not so long ago.
And it's just like, man, that's just in your pocket. Oh.
Especially the new Androids like the galaxy note 10 yeah.
Has the ability to blur the background, like portrait mode in four K video.
So you're making four K video, not just blurred,
but they also have this filter that you can make the background kind of fucked
up and scratchy like an old VHS tape. Okay.
You could do cool effects with video while in real time.
Yeah.
I mean they also have wide angle lenses so you can film and take photos and wide
angle.
They have night vision mode where it turns night into I'm a much more visible
environment. It's, it's weird. It's weird and it's still early.
That's the crazy thing is that it's still early.
I love the fact that we're all competing with each other, right?
Like Apple has to come up with something better than Samsung's done and Huawei
and you know, one plus,
it's like it's this mad dash to come up with the greatest shit the world's ever
seen. Everyone's doing it.
I do think that it would be good to have a little bit of a moratorium on new
phones though. Really? Why? Oh, they won't do it, but I never, no,
of course not. Of course not. They want to keep the competition going,
keep people fired up. But the differences between them now are so incremental.
It's just diminishing returns now. So you know,
if he put out a new phone every six months or every 12 months,
the difference between them now is kinda like sort of,
but the difference between like if you look at like the screen real estate of
like a galaxy note 10 versus an iPod, iPhone 10 which is what I have. But yeah,
10 S max. Okay.
That was the shit just a few months ago. Yeah.
But when you look at that next to like Steve Aoki was here yesterday and he had
a galaxyS 10 plus. Is that what it was?
That thing looks way cooler than this. Like you were looking at.
I'm right next to each other like, Oh there's no,
there's no bezels on the outside and there no notch at the top. Yeah.
This is a tiny little hole where the camera is. I'm like, Oh yeah. What?
I guess what I mean is like the difference between the galaxyS five and the E
ssex edge was like a big leap. Right.
And then between the six and the seven,
little less between the seven and the S eight little less. I mean, between you,
what do you got over there? What do you use? This is a one plus six. Oh,
well I'll give them a much, give them a shout out. Um, that's a great phone.
One plus makes a great phone as sort of unheralded phone and they have the very
best in screen fingerprint reader apparently. Yeah.
So shout out to Flossy Carter teaching me. Yeah.
So they've made three new ones since this version.
I only got this last year, but this is already three generations.
Let me see that. And that's pretty fucking cool. The new ones plus seven,
the one plus seven has a, a full screens.
I've got Megatron on the back today. Oh, nice.
The one plus seven has a full screen. There's no notch at all.
There's nothing about camera. Camera go and a little motor. Yeah.
Which is pretty incredible. Yeah.
A lot of people here don't seem to know one plus. No.
Everyone seems confused by my phone here. Right. That's everybody's Apple.
Crazy. Okay. Okay. It's everyone's locked into the ecosystem. Okay.
Apple has done an amazing job of roping everybody into their ecosystem.
100% with iMessage and with airdrop. Okay.
Those two things and FaceTime and FaceTime. We're thing over here.
Everybody FaceTimes people is a new thing.
Like I got FaceTime calls from my friends. I just FaceTime me out of the blue.
I'm like, all right guys,
we're going to talk on video and then they're there and then your video too,
like the first one to do it to me was killer Mike.
I was taking a shit and killer Mike FaceTimes me. I'm like, what's up man?
But apparently kids would do it. Andrew Schultz does it. A lot of,
a lot of people just FaceTime people now. That's the new thing. Yeah.
People are into FaceTiming.
Schulz is an interesting example because he's a God that couldn't get a Netflix
deal, couldn't get a comedy central deal, so he said, okay, I know what I'll do.
I know I've got great comedy.
I will just put it all on YouTube and he created this YouTube channel.
He put his, his stand up comedy special.
He was self-produced it paid for everything,
put it up on YouTube and it's got millions of views and he went from being a guy
that didn't really sell out clubs all that often to selling out theaters,
multiple shows, and it happened inside of a year. Yeah,
just all self-made,
all done by himself with the people that he works with,
he puts little clips on his Instagram, they get hyped up,
he promotes them that way.
He puts clips on YouTube and now other comics are following suit and they're
realizing like, Hey, this is the way to do this.
And so many people can watch YouTube on their television now. Oh yeah,
of course. Yeah. Just the opportunity out there right now is, is incredible.
Yeah, it's incredible. I, I posted a dumb
nine second video on Twitter and you know,
got international international coverage on it.
I've been invited to fly out to LA. I'm now on, you know,
the Joe Rogan experience doing all these other podcasts and it's just,
it's just nuts, you know? And you can't eat for that. Oh, of course. Yeah.
What do people say? Well, 99.5% was positive.
Most people got it. Um, the people who were angry,
it was kind of funny because people were angry for different reasons because a
lot of people didn't get it. So I don't want to say a lot of people,
a few people didn't get it.
So some people were upset with me saying that what I did who was not fair
towards women.
It's kind of like you kind of got the point,
but you also sort of usually missed it know. So I got some people saying that,
Oh, you know, you're not a real woman and you shouldn't be doing this.
What you did was unfair against women and blah, blah, blah, ditch tenders.
I'm kinda like, dude, you're always gonna have people that need,
you need them to dig holes. Yeah. Yeah. And that did not gonna get it. And that,
and then of course there were the people who were trying to say that it was some
attack on trans people as a whole or the entire trans community or something,
something like this. And it was just like, no,
it's just making a very biological, factual point.
This is not an attack on any individual nor group. And like you said,
I mean online, once we had,
as people try to read malice and stuff into things that's not there,
someone will see one tweet and they'll start coming up with all these weird
assumptions about what you believe or what they think you are or whatever,
and you're just like, no, that's not what I said. That's not what I believe.
I just said what I said. I did what I did.
One of the interesting things about tweets, right,
is that if you can define someone in 140 characters,
I'm pegging it moron who's this and that and boom. Yeah.
And then you send that tweet out there and then you know, you read it and like,
Hey, that's not me. No, but it's,
these mischaracterizations are so easy when there's 140 characters or 280
characters. A lot of it is malice too. You know,
if people don't understand something or something goes against their beliefs or
their ideology,
it's a lot easier to just try to demonize the person who's saying it or slap
some kind of label on them, which means that you can just ignore that person.
Right? Yeah. It's, people tried to do it all the time.
It's not something that works with me because I'm very aware and cognizant of
these types of tactics and stuff people try to use to mob people or shut them
down or whatever. So it doesn't work on me personally.
Like I've had tons of mobs come after me and try to, you know,
label me some shit. They're reasonable. Yeah.
This is the thing that just,
it just doesn't work because I don't play into the game.
Like they just ended up looking silly cause they'll say something and you're
just like, no.
Well you've got your finger on the pulse of culture and all these shifting tides
and turns. Where do you think this is going?
Because this is not something that we experienced 10 15 years ago. This is,
this is all like the boiling is completely new.
Yeah. You, where do you think this is going? That's a good question.
I is like a particular aspect of it.
Do you mean the political stuff or the animosity for sure.
Because it seems heightened. It is heightened.
It seems more people are particularly politically more polarized now than ever
before.
The quickest I've ever seen for people to label someone a bigot or a racist or a
trans folk or a sexist.
It's like everyone wa there's,
there's so much intensity involved in discourse today that I attribute some of
it to the dismay of having a maniac in the white house, you know? Well,
he's into that. He's more of a symptom than a cause.
It was already happening and I'd already seen it happening. Yeah.
So that's a big reason why he won as far as I'm concerned. Um,
because people were getting tired of some of the nonsense, you know,
people are getting tired of, I often joke, I mean it,
it seems like in 2015 and 2016 the, the strategy of, you know,
some of the democratic party was to call half the population racist and that
didn't work.
So now they're strategies to call 70% of the population racist and hope it works
and
it doesn't work.
I mean it doesn't endear people to you if you're trying to win people over then
trying to call them things that are not is really not a good idea.
And a big problem with it as well is one, it dilutes the terms, right?
When people start throwing around these terms,
racist Nazi white supremacists are diluted the terms completely because if you
start with Apple and Google a, which one are they called? Ben Shapiro,
who's a Jew, an Orthodox Jew, they call two Orthodox Jew or one of those.
And uh, Dennis Prager was also Jewish.
They labeled them an internal memos as Nazis. It's insane. Nazi.
It's crazy. Yeah. I've been called a Nazi. Woo. I'm a young black man. Um,
I'll be called a white two. I'm being called a black white supremacist.
I'm not even joking. [inaudible] yeah,
so like Clayton Bigsby from Chappelle show.
I wish I were joking.
I'm best thing is like three of the people who have called me that were white
too. So I was just like, you can see the ridiculousness of what you're,
what you're saying here.
So people just throw around these labels and I think there's a problem for a lot
of reasons. I think one,
it massively minimises the reality of people who have actually gone through some
crap or been oppressed or something like that.
If you start just tossing these things around,
if you start comparing stuff to Nazi Germany or whatever,
the people who genuinely went through that stuff will be like, wait,
what are you even talking about? Right? That's not fair. Number two is it just,
um, it makes it really hard to actually,
what's the time it sort of dilutes the terms.
So things that should have a sting lose their sting.
If you're going to just call everybody racist,
you're gonna call everybody a white supremist,
you're going to call everybody these things,
then it [inaudible] these words lose their power. And then third,
it actually provides cover for genuine people who hold these views,
right? Like white supremacists, not some big popular common thing,
but you know, those people do still exist. Neo Nazis do actually exist.
And you're providing massive cover for them all.
If you're going to just start going around and banding out these terms, what,
like Willy nilly, because now when people hear those terms, if you hear, Oh,
so and so is called a Nazi, now my default that you know,
10 years ago I would've been like, Oh really? Like, we know what is this,
this serious now? I mean, now it's like, Oh,
do you mean like an actual Nazi or do you mean like a,
an immediate immediate Wolf? Exactly, exactly. And you know,
it just begins to the stage where words just lose their meanings and I don't
even know. I don't take these accusations even seriously anymore.
And a lot of people feel the same way because so many people have been called
these things. I mean,
do you think it's going to normalize where everyone's going to calm down or
anything? It's going to keep ramping up? It's a good question. Um,
I think it depends on whether or not Donald Trump wins again.
I think if he wins again, it might ramp up.
I think he will win again because it's ramping up. Um,
I think that people need to chill. That's really,
that's really what it is. People need to chill and not get so caught up in,
you know, it's so weird.
We're living in this time where people are saying that gender is a spectrum,
but yet politics is binary. Okay, so your left,
you're on the left or you're on the right. That's good point. That's it.
And it's like, no. Most people, I mean, firstly,
most people are relatively apolitical.
Most people are not actually that politically charged. Like, right. You know,
people are busy. Most people,
most people just want to get on with their lives and not really be bothered
getting fucked over in their taxes. They want their schools to be good. Yeah.
Yeah. And they're not, you know, they don't want people to be discriminated. No,
they're not. Right. Exactly.
They're not ride or die for the blue team or ride to die for the red team.
You know? It's so weird when they are too. Yeah.
It is exhausting when you're around someone who's really political or like,
Oh yeah, I mean, I get it. If that's your, your job.
And that's what you do and whatnot. But ultimately, look,
all these people have to live in the same town, city, country, planet.
So we need a way for all of these people and all of this diversity on all levels
to work and function and people don't step on each other's toes too much and
everyone can do that.
Things have their beliefs how their views and not massively encroach on other
people. And I think, I think we'd actually work that out pretty well.
I want to say in like the late nineties to early 2010s stuff seemed certainly in
the West like okay, we've kinda kind of got it here.
And that's why I feel a little bit dismayed when I see some of these ideas
popping up or some of this identity politics,
nonsense and stuff popping up over the last five to six years.
And people are kind of falling back into this very tribal mentality,
whether it's men versus women or black versus white or red versus blue or remain
versus leave, whatever it is. I'm just kind of like, look,
I look at people as individuals and people I'm not going to be, you know,
I'm not running around the street trying to find how do we promote that though?
How do we have promotion looking at people as individuals because I think that
is really that, that's,
that's one of the keys to getting out of this mess it is,
is to stop tribal ideological recognition and definitions of humans just to look
at peoples, this is Tom, this is Sally, this is this guy,
this is that girl. This is this non-binary person. Whatever the fuck they are.
I think there's a lot to learn from children in that regard because I don't
think kids generally do that. Kids don't care. Give a fuck. Kids don't care.
I mean, where I grew up in Saudi Arabia,
I mean off the bat I was just surrounded by people of all different skin colors,
different nationalities, different religions, and it was just always cool.
Some of these ideas,
like I'd never heard people talking about race anytime more in my life than now.
Mm. Which is really weird to me. Right. You know, in, in the nineties,
in the thousands, I wasn't hearing people talking about, you know,
white privilege, this white or that your white man that way.
And suddenly it's like, you know, Oh let me tell you about my,
my blackness or you know,
you're hearing terms like blackness and whiteness and I'm just like,
what are you even talking about? Like this is, this is nonsense.
People of color, this guy, I can't stand that term by the way. Um,
they don't like just all this terminology and people are just talking in these
really bizarre ways and just kind of grouping people into these weird groups
that I'm just like,
what's the point of all this? What's the purpose? You get some juice out of it,
you know? That's why it's for them. It's worth the squeeze. Yeah.
Cause they get something, you know,
they get something by appealing to fellow Europeans or by appealing to,
you know, like the straight pride parade, you know,
they got a bunch of people to fucking parade. They got together.
Like I'm so proud of being straight. Like, Oh great, you're proud of being,
90% of the fucking population shaped people are under attack.
Like w what does that mean? That is so crazy. I don't know.
I pride make sense. They w S the,
I know a bunch of guys,
well I know at least three that are in the closet that want to come out.
But camp, they're scared. Yeah. Whether it's because of their career,
cause their life, you know, they're gay amongst their friends.
They'll let their friend, but they don't want to tell anybody.
So for them it's like a lot of conservatives, right? Gay.
Gay is the only thing that you can hide,
right? Like if, if you're black, it's obvious.
If you're white, it's obvious. If you're gay, no one knows. No one knows.
So you can hear people say gay jokes and say no things and,
and you could just swallow it and like, you know, and you could feel
terrible and you could hear pastors talk about are you going to hell if you're
gay? And you're like fuck. And they are gay and they can't come out.
So for them, the idea of gay pride make sense? It's a celebration.
It's an affirmation that it's okay to be who you are. Yeah, that's,
that makes sense. Straight pride is fucking preposterous. It's so ridiculous,
man. Every fucking, most people are straight. Bitch. What are you doing?
You're taking time out of your busy day and you're going to March.
You got to fly. What's if, if the gape pride thing is a rainbow,
what a, what a straight people get. I don't know. What's the flag?
It's kinda greedy. They took the whole rainbow though. They did.
They stole it from the leprechauns greeting. What is the, uh,
let's stop and think about that.
Like what does the straight pride flag w what color would it be? Um,
maybe all black or all white. I don't know. Black and white. I don't know. Hmm.
What does that black and white is? The black and white for real. There's a frog.
The result. I said fag. I meant to say flag. Sorry. Canceled.
Uh, really? There's Googled it. There's pictures of these.
Please put up the fucking stray. Oh, there we go. Yeah. Black Christ.
It's exactly what I thought it would be.
I was going to say it'll happen to male and females and fucking nailed it. Yeah,
look at that. That's incredible. Like a meme, but I don't know bro.
We need to get that hang one of those in the studio. Straight fried with flag.
Holy shit. Holy shit.
There's a straight pride flag is flex for everything, you know.
I know God damn it. That's hilarious though. Meanwhile, the gay one,
they have a way better flag. Make America straight again. Oh my God.
Oh my God. It's straight, dude. That's why there's so many of us.
You fucking America is mostly straight.
That's why this 320 million people. Oh God.
Yeah man. Look at people. People can do what they want, man. I have the facts.
I was joking thinking this is a straight pride flag and the fact that you nailed
it perfectly. Oh, it's probably black and white. That's another one.
Red and pink and blew the fuck out of here with that one. Nah.
Is that another one? Yeah. Oh, so there,
this does division amongst the straight pride folks.
They can't decide what's what. It's great to be straight. Look at those. Oh,
what do you get? What do you get people that no one wants a fuck. Look at them.
Look at them. That guy's got an American flag bandana. Bitch,
you ain't Hulk Hogan. He take that goddamn thing off right now.
But a bandana around his head stop.
Oh well what do we do? Zoghbi Oh,
keep doing. Keep doing what we're doing man. I think discussion,
to answer your question, I think discussion is what is needed to keep the,
keep the lid on the lid, on the pot. I think.
I think that's why as you know,
when we were talking about like de platforming and all that kind of stuff,
all that stuff plays into the polarization as far as I'm concerned. I agree. Um,
you know,
it drives people underground and pushes people to radical fringes and whatnot.
What you want is just keep the communication channels open. I mean,
you've only got three ways of dealing with any conflict. You can talk,
you can segregate or you can fight.
Doesn't matter if you're talking individually or countries that those are the
only three options.
So as soon as discussion breaks down or people don't want to talk or people
think, Oh, I can't talk to that person because they,
they voted Trump or if they've voted leave or they voted liberal or they voted
Democrat or whatever. As soon as that breaks down and I mean it's crazy.
You've seen all these stories about couples breaking up or families where the
parents won't talk to their kids anymore or vice versa, or people are kind of,
you know,
exilic and denouncing their own friends and family over politics and when I see
stuff like that, I'm like, that is sad. It's very, very sad. I mean if you,
you can have a disagreement, you can say, okay, I believe in this. I think this,
I'm going to vote that way. You vote that way. Cool.
But you can still be friends, you can still be brothers.
You can still be cool like that stuff. I mean,
if stuff is functioning correctly,
politics shouldn't play such a huge role in your life.
It should be a very much a background thing. You know what I mean?
It's just there, um, mean one of the main characteristics and cults yeah.
Is to separate you from anybody that disagrees. It is, it really is.
That's one of the things that they do in college.
They separate you from your family. It's one of the first things they do. It is,
and that's how people end up in echo chambers. People are like, Oh,
how did we not see Trump coming?
It's like you didn't see Trump coming because you don't talk to half the
population. Right.
And if you live in these high population areas where everyone has the same sort
of ideology that shares that ideology, it becomes a real problem.
New York and LA in particular. Yeah. It's weird. I mean, it happens.
The two things it, I guess it happens with most are uh, politics and religion,
right?
So if you live in a place where everybody is religious and everybody is of the
same faith,
then it's easy to sort of assume and behave in a way that everybody else in the
world or outside thinks and believes the exact same things.
Everybody you know does the same thing can happen politically.
If someone lives in a, you know,
a super liberal area or a super conservative area, you can just think,
okay well everyone, everyone I know thinks this.
So that's what everybody thinks. Yeah. And a lot of people,
I mean I'm a musician, you're a comedian.
We both go around respective countries to,
to different places and you talk to different people. You have this podcast,
you've had all kinds of people of different persuasions on here,
religious nonreligious, you know,
political all across the spectrum and whatever.
So I'd imagine that you can understand and empathize with all of the positions.
You've got your own views. But it can be like, okay, I get what I get,
where that person is coming from or I get how that person believes that or I are
get that. And just that level of empathy is really what is needed.
I think it's really just about empathy.
It's about being able to understand that most people,
most people want the world to be a better place.
There aren't that many people who wake up every thinking are,
I want to make the world worse.
I want to make my life where don't want to make my families let.
Most people want to make stuff better.
People have different ideas on what will make things better,
but I think as long as people sort of extend that charity to other people and
don't try to consider things in the worst possible way.
If somebody says something, whether online or offline,
don't try to interpret it in the worst possible way that you could or read some
kind of malice into it that's not there.
Just understand that coming from a good place,
you may disagree and then you can have that discussion and even if people don't
change their minds, you at least under
stand other people better. I think you're entirely right.
I think the idea that we can get through this world existing in echo chambers
and solve anything is ridiculous. Yeah. We have to communicate with each other.
Absolutely. You know, one of the talked to someone and they said, uh, how,
this is a real weird conversation I had. They were like,
how do you talk to so many different people,
people that you agree with and disagree with? I go, well,
I find things that I agree with even in people that I disagree with. Yeah.
I try to find like common ground, you know, it's like is that old sting song?
The Russians love their children too, you know? Okay. I don't think I
thought of it for whatever reason, but it's theirs. We all,
you can find things that you agree with,
with people you can find common ground. Yeah.
Morals and ethics and kindness and communication.
Compassion and comradery and friendship.
And we work out from there and try to figure out why does someone have these
politically polarizing views.
Why does someone have this idea about that or this and let's figure out what the
fuck the middle ground is. And you know,
and freedom is a big part of it, man. You know,
and the more people restricting people and the more people are trying to enforce
their ideology on other people,
the more the other side's gonna dig their heels in and then you get this,
this stance that we're at today.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, one of my things, I mean like I myself, you know,
I believe in God. I'm a Christian, always have been.
And one thing I often say is I think, you know,
if you're taking something like religion,
I always say like if someone says I can't do such and such because it's against
my religion, that's totally cool.
If you start saying you can't do such and such because it's against my religion,
right? That's when that line gets crossed, right?
When you start trying to force things down other people's throats and trying to,
you know, try and change all that. So, and I think that's something that,
you know, not everyone is, not everybody is there yet,
but I think most people sort of implicitly understand that, you know? Okay,
cool. Like everyone, people can have all their different,
their different beliefs,
their different ideas or lack of belief or whatever the case is.
But as long as you're not trying to force stuff from other people, you know,
people don't like being forced.
People generally don't like being forced to do things or to,
to believe things were being, being punished for what they, what they think,
what they believe in, whatever.
So when you, wherever that comes from, I think if you start having that,
whether it's from a government or an individual or whatever,
that's when people are really gonna clash and collide and there seems to be,
there seem to be a lot of people right now who don't really get like that. It's,
you know, think like us think like me or we will punish you. Yeah.
And that's not primarily coming in the West anyway.
That's not generally coming from religious people. Now I'm not seeing,
it's more of a of a political thing. You know,
like we were talking about some of these,
some of this weird intersectional far left kind of stuff.
That's very much what they're doing now.
Even when you're talking about them ostracizing people or camp trying to cancel
people or whatever, it's very much like, look, this is what we think.
There's what we believe. Anyone who doesn't,
if you're not with us or you're against us and we more,
we're going to attack you. We're gonna verbally demonize you.
We're going to D platform. You were going to do all this. And I'm like, look,
that's, that's a problem. You can't be claiming to be tolerant.
And then you're treating people that way and you're talking about people that
way. All that's going to do is keep raising the temperature, right.
Temperature down. Yeah. Well said. It's a very,
very important what you just said, the way he said I it.
And there's also a tremendous amount of unhealthy people,
unhealthy, emotionally unhealthy,
physically unhealthy in terms of their perspective and their,
their ability to be objective about the world they live in and to be
introspective about their own fallen failings and shortcomings and just to treat
people well.
I think if we all went through this life with that as our directive,
let's treat people well. I'm going to treat people well and be nice to people.
Try to be friendly as much as possible and try to do my best. Yeah. You know,
treat. Do you know who Don Miguel Ruiz is? I don't.
Four agreements. I think there's like five agreements now. I don't think so. Um,
see if you could pull up what the four agreements are. It's uh,
be impeccable with your word. Always do your best.
Um, why can I not remember them? See it. Pull it. Pull them out please.
You got it. Here we go. Yeah. Um, there we go.
The impeccable you were. Don't take anything personally. Don't make assumptions.
That's three. That's three. Where's the rest of them go? Oh, that's hilarious.
But there's more than that. Be impeccable with your word.
Don't take anything personally. Don't make assumptions.
Always do your best though.
Always do your best as missing from that for whatever reason. That's hilarious.
So that they, there's only three, but that's Wikipedia.
Get the fuck out of Wikipedia. Go to that four agreements though.
The website right there. Bam. Okay, here. This is, it's a really good book.
Okay.
And it's very interesting because it's very simple and they added a fifth one C,
be impeccable with your word. Don't take anything personally.
Don't make assumptions. Always do your best,
but just those being impeccable with your word. [inaudible] very important,
right? Yeah. Say what you mean mean what you say and if you fuck up,
be honest about it. Yeah. Don't take anything personally.
That's very important and I've worked very hard to develop that in myself,
that [inaudible] people saying things about me or whether it's something that
goes wrong or someone fucked me over.
I try to take a deep breath and I try to forgive them. Yeah, I really do.
I work hard at it. Yeah. Don't make assumptions. That's another one.
Don't make assumptions. It's not,
does no value in that and always doing your best man.
You can't go wrong if you always do your best.
It's one of the best things anybody could say in life,
and I think the other one he's got a new one is be skeptical,
but be open to do information. I think that's what it is. Be skeptical,
but learn to listen. There is, yeah. These are great.
So he added one because he realized, yeah man,
I need another agreement to really good. It's a very simple book.
Not a super complicated book, but those tenants ways to live by,
I mean that is a great way for people,
especially people that are secular that don't believe in religion.
Like that is a good structure.
And I think that one of the things that religious people have an advantage in is
that they do have a moral and ethical structure to live their life by.
And if you live your life by that, look, when I was young,
I used to think there was something wrong with it. I was think, well,
it's all fairytales and nonsense. Why would you believe in that?
And then as I got older I realized, well, no, no, no.
If you just follow the tenants of it, I'm like, that's a great ethical,
moral structure to live your life by. Yeah.
And I think there's great benefit in people and there's a lot of people that
find tremendous benefit and living life with, you know, guidelines. Yeah.
Guidelines on how to be kindness. I mean, as a Christian, I mean, if you,
if you try to somewhat live your life like Jesus, it's hard to go wrong.
Really go wrong. Yeah. I mean even if someone doesn't believe in,
I would tell people, I'm like, look, regardless of what you believe,
you can't say that that guy is a bad example of a role model.
I know it says Jesus was a Dick. Yeah. Help help people.
You know, right now Jesus was a Dick. Right.
That's probably a T shirt being constructive. Right. You know,
someone who's been listening to your podcast for a long time.
Actually that's something that's a I what you just said is something that I've
noticed a change in actually over the years. Um, you know,
going back and listening to some,
some of the older ones where I think you were a lot more, I would have put it,
not aggressive, but, um,
a lot less tolerant of say like religion and religious viewpoints and
discharged. Yeah. Yeah. And I think more recent, you know,
more recently over the years it's been like, okay, I can,
I can get where that's coming from. And what the value is and whatnot. Well,
I have a great benefit from this podcast. Yeah.
I know other people benefit from it,
but I've experienced a great benefit and that I've,
I've been exposed to a lot of different points of view, different personalities,
different intellects and different brilliant human beings that have very
different ideologies. I'm, I've,
I've met brilliant people that I love and respect that have polar opposite ideas
on how the world works on both sides. I mean, it's,
and through that I've developed a,
a sort of an understanding of the various mechanisms that are at play with why
people believe what they believe and how they benefit from believing that and
what's the pros and cons.
And then I've just sort of opened my mind up much more to various viewpoints.
Yeah. Financial viewpoints, political viewpoints,
and I've developed a much greater appreciation for the variety of opinions and
ideas. Yeah. Yeah. No, that's been, it's been awesome to see like, uh, I've,
I've noticed it in myself and been like, ah, that's, that's cool.
That's kind of, I realized how dumb I am about a lot things.
I mean, if I had lived my life, like I'd be being honest,
if I had lived my life without doing this podcast,
I would probably be a far more ignorant person right now in the same place.
I feel like I've gotten not just great conversations and met great people like
yourself and had a great time.
But also I've been very privileged to have a tremendous education through all
these people and for many of their books and, and Brian after you right now,
Neil, the grass Tyson's coming on, that's all. So I'm fucking pumped.
You can meet him. He's in the green room. Amen. Yeah. Awesome.
So it's like having these incredible people to share their knowledge and a
lifetime of learning. You know,
they can fill in blanks and educate you and point you in the right direction.
And also you can see the way their mind works. And then there's guys like,
you know, like David Goggins who just, you realize like, Oh, okay,
there's levels to everything, man. This fucking dude, you know, he will,
he will make you realize that you have more in the tank.
He will make you realize that you can do more, you can push more.
He fucking sends me text messages all the time.
Like he sent me one yesterday and they just come out of the blue and uh,
like it is no rhyme or reason. There's nothing going on. No need to respond.
Hope all is well. Brother continued to live in the grip of life as you know,
nothing gets done by being a bitch. Stay hard brother,
as amazing. Oh wow. Wow.
And I get on my fucking hands, touch sweating. I'm like, I'm not a pitch.
I'm going to run fucking left. Well that's crazy dude. Like I said,
I mean it's all about potential then and I,
I love and I'm drawn to anybody who promotes potential and being and becoming
your best.
I think that's part of why what you do here has been so successful and so
inspirational to people all over the world because you promote that you promote
being, being your best. You can be better, you can be smarter,
you can learn more, you can be stronger, you can be wiser. All of that support.
Same thing with guys like Jordan Peterson.
I think so much of his success is it's like, look, you've got this potential,
you can, you can do this man. You know,
and that's the same message I've always tried to put out through my music and
everything that I do. I want to inspire people, I want to motivate people. So,
and I just think it's so necessary right now. It really is so necessary.
People are just floundering or spinning their wheels and just directionless and
it's kinda sad to see and it's just like, you know, we can all do so much more.
It is sad to see,
but there's also a light at the end of the tunnel because there's people like
you out there. There's,
there's people that are searching to improve themselves and they're honest about
where they are right now and they're honest about their failings and
shortcomings and they're also telling other people about it,
which I think is so important because if someone sees you and you know you're a
guy who's on the radio or television,
or maybe you're a rap star and you're killing it, you're killing it.
They assume all this guy is just, he just is there. He's just a winner.
He's just there. And then you know,
you could tell people about your trials and tribulations about your failings and
shortcomings about your thoughts and insecurities about all the things that
tripped you up and all the things that you learned that allowed you to advance
and to be a better person. That's what it's all about. Like all the time,
every day it's about learning how to be a better person and there's no finish
line doesn't mean even the fucking Dalai Lama,
I don't know if you've been paying attention,
but he got canceled recently in general.
The Dalai Lama guy said something slightly sex and stuff.
He said the next fucking 80 year old man who was picked to be the Dalai Lama,
female, they need to be attractive because no one, no one wants to do.
No one wants to look at an ugly faces.
No one who makes an ugly face like, dude,
he's an 80 year old human being. That's what he is. And he's also a guy with,
he has never had a real job, has never had a perform. And I mean there's,
there's a lot of people out there that can do better and they know they can do
better and they just lack the tools and they lack the understanding.
And I think a person like yourself,
or hopefully me and then certainly a lot of the people that I've had on the
podcast, they can give people an example and they can say, Oh,
this guy used to be a loser and he figured out how to not be, I can do,
like you look at Goggins,
he used to be 300 pounds of fat and eating milkshakes and then it becomes this
fucking maniac who runs a hundred mile races day after day. You know, you,
you can do something extraordinary with your life and you don't have to be the
guy who pushes himself physically to you, almost dead.
And you don't have to be the guy that writes the most books. You'd be, yeah,
but you could find your thing. Whatever your thing is,
whether it's just being a better father or a husband or a friend,
or a bit better at your job or better at your craft, like whatever it is, man,
we can all be better, can all be better, and that's how you make society better,
the world better. Right. That's it. To be your good man. Thank you, sir.
Thanks so much, man. And everybody, this is available. Yeah. Perseverance.
My new album, it's available right now. It's available right now. iTunes,
Spotify, Google. Play everywhere.
Your podcasts also real talk with Zubi is out right now.
I'm a subscriber and I saw strong advice. You can get that at join teams.
zubi.com all right. Thank you brother. Appreciate it, man.
Thanks for being here. Bye everybody.
Thank you, Matt. Appreciate.